[Music]
n
n n
[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
n
n yeah
yeah we back it's the New Year y'all M
check mik check what's going on how we
doing out here let talk to y'all it's
been a minute feel like talk to y'all in
a minute no more Oscar what's up Kevin
what up live Supremacy is going on how
my levels is I'm feel like a rookie
right now I don't remember doing
this been off too long Mike's hot [__]
Mike's hot hot hot
to fuzzy what's going on oh man y'all up
in here K what's up Zach Riley bats
what's going on back from there my man
Craig hully hul's on Deck what's up
Anonymous boss yeah Anonymous you don't
know who he
is James Morrison what's going on Gerald
Matthew OG what's going on live suery
what up yeah yeah I'm G to make a quick
roll call Cuz uh started stream a little
late because um what you call addict's
doing was doing the stream before plus I
got to get back in Pocket man
that that time off was was too
good but this flu is real y'all
everybody going through some type of
this flu is real seasonal flu King in
here oh got mute y' mics see y'all in a
[Music]
minute
n
[Music]
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lord's podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understand I kill a beat
they want to compare me to Freddy and
Jason I rather be hanbal they be like
why use a video game just be original
yall Dramatical I know it's random but I
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they they can sing
up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting and range you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest started regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my voal all on Twitter but I'm
antisocial love my city but I'm still by
coal I got let's Swit that what did you
do Don't Stop N that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoiled feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't here the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vult Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being a accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original yall too Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting and range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but Bal I got you let's
Swit that what you stop that was dope
keep that keep that going keep that
going go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault Tron with a gang of cougars
and I'm going places better tell a uber
cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go go
ahead and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a canable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being account accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
that they can Saron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a you got check my vocals all
on Twitter but I'm antisocial love my
city but I'm still by coal I got let's
Swit that up what you do Don't Stop N
that was dope keep that keep that keep
that going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you can say that I'm very
SPO to be your dog thing very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making vult Tron with
a gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get the
show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all could Dramatical I
know it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arsing up in
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
started regardless back we was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I
[Music]
got
call loud and clear a of invitation turn
not on
me I cry the Praises of the
life
onal the River St Lawrence with a St
[Music]
through I'mma just chill and watch them
many snacks in the attic I wanted to
chill with the pack and be like a young
whoop but then they will mistake me for
addict if I can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cuz if you don't
give her that option you going to be
single player like s you going to get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to a Elemental what an avatar to a knee
Bender I got to be Meo I know it's my
destiny work to coo who cares if you fly
if you still a mosquito you swear you
ain't something but really be steo you
like to collect stuff and that's cool
but I got bad news even if you really
was that dude King still be the king of
the statu since a juvenile I've been
cursed with a curse to be Musical and if
you hate it we'll meet in The Crucible
other than that it's cool and it's
beautiful we let you know that your
dreams are pursuable whatever you want
to do then it's doable if you got work
on a Sunday it's suitable cuz you can
listen to this in your cubicle on the
Lord's Day
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a L's
[Music]
day but yeah we to this is mike check
mike check real quick see how your
levels is oh oh all right all right adct
oh I need hello yeah he said hello hello
well hello there hello well hello good
people yes yes all right that's good
that's good we GNA get this p and get
this cracky Ling and I was looking for
that oh you looking for what you I was
looking for the
this looking for get the grave beard
right you know CU I wasn't able to go to
the barber shop because I a't want to
bring him whatever I got oh no took care
I was like bro this flu going around
he's like I got you HEK he threw the
mask on me I was like so I was like yo
you know the mustache and and you got to
get the side yeah don't Bo I was like
all right all right he had it down to a
side you know
postco yeah now now now my dude I was
just like you know what I'm not even G
to show up there you know I'm not even
going to show up cuz I don't need to be
coughing and hacking the lacking you
know what I'm saying coughing in the
back of the hack of the lack yeah
back can't be coughing like that can't
be coughing like that no doubt here ye
here ye and we are live happy New Year
welcome to
202024 and welcome to the IR Lords
podcast LLC and also live on Lords of
gaming.net episode number
335 another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's day and
today we've got Xbox next in 202 six
rumors wow insomniacs data
breach sucks for them XBox exclusive
going
[Music]
multiplat and Horizon MMO to PC and
mobile to discuss so we wait wait what
wait wait a second wait wait wait how
wait what why that title wasn't phrased
like how it it's supposed to be phrased
though where where was it supposed to be
phrased I see the title that you said me
oh okay yeah I just read what you said
me you know K like to dispute it own no
no no I just I you know Skip skipping
somebody but we'll talk about it oh okay
we can talk okay okay okay I got I got
what you saying No Doubt so let's
introduce the for well we're missing one
but don't no no worries I've been told
Lord s is joining in progress so no
worries we be getting our brother soon
but we still got the original Lord here
at the round table my co-host the co
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of the
spin clap and how of the young wolf M
Lord adct back to back how we doing sir
doing pretty good for those of you that
missed uh the community stream we uh we
played a good hour and a half of Halo
what's funny is the reason that the um
the shadow uh the shadow stream
the ra Shadow Legend I always the shadow
Street the
shadow Tong Twisted myself man Tong
Twisted myself ra Shadow Legends
twisting your tongue huh cuz I wanted I
wanted to play more I wanted to play uh
more more Halo with the community that's
so we we we played till like it's like
11:30 and I was like man I got I gotta I
gotta go like yeah I saw that I popped
up I I was laying in the bed you know
I'm tossing and turning with the with
whatever I got and I looked over and I
was like ironin Lords on MM Community
stream I was like what the hell is going
on then I saw adct I tuned in adct had
grabbed the flag and he was running
getting back this I'm like yeah go at it
go at it and he running and he like they
snatched out flag and AD like man you
know what to do you know what to do get
him so they get him right and then as
adct is showing up they grabbed our flag
and adct had his flag in the hand
punched him in the
mouth but then at the same time do hit
him then adct fell out he said if you
guys don't get
this yeah it was dope I'm here to tell
you king we won that game pretty sure
you was cuz you was on some real General
stuff right there we won that game won
that game the game was won we we we we
got it but shout out to ra Shadow
Legends you know they uh they sponsor
that the community stream me me uh I
have met my match there
there's some there's some hard ingame
content on that stuff man like and
what's what I like is if in order to
make characters stronger you need
certain stuff and they tell you where to
go they okay go grind there it's here
just go grind go and once you start
doing a certain level you're like oh
okay I need to go level up now okay and
then once you get people like really
leveled up oh I need better
characters that's how go they they were
they were coming at me man like it's
it's like a very strategic game
highend and like there's there's like
this Elite dungeon Super Dungeon they
call it or super raid not even happening
can't can't even can't even take him
halfway but not even halfway 10% Dam
like it just it's crazy but you know so
but how how overall how do you like the
game though I liked it it's a fun game
you know it's a turn-based game we don't
we don't really get those type of games
especially like in the mobile market
market like that you know this this
thing was on on mobile it's it's it's on
the phones well that is
[Music]
mobile you know and they need to Port
that sucker to to to consoles I'd
actually play that it be crazy if it can
go on Portal but oh no that doesn't do
that oh see there you go there you go
it's got its own Clan I's got its own
Clan I need to get over there then to
jump in there yo I'm watching turn adex
mic up I was like he sound fine to me
but all right they like to hear Bo yeah
they want you just a littleit I just
turned my mic up twice okay I just want
to make sure what's funny is like I'll
turn it up again and then people you too
loud man too loud right now that one
that one that one right there is not
exactly now we
good yeah bring that down now what about
now sounds good to me sounds good to me
you too loud too l oh my Dragon Ball B
shirt yeah I I okay I respect you Fred
uh right cuz you you called it a Dragon
Ball zirt not a Dragon Ball Z this is
Dragon Ball this is the original OG the
OG OG okay this is when Goku was a
kid don't know there the difference yeah
uh yo I got somebody comment had to be
held that was crazy YouTube shut someone
down before they can get loose and I saw
what they about to say and they's like
nah we good on you
that's been it sir yeah it's been it you
know been playing a lot of Halo infinite
lately like it abur amount I've been
playing two three four hours a day
almost it feels like yeah I maxed out
two of the battle passes like damn like
it's it's crazy and they let you do
custom games and get XP for it what yeah
it's just it's it it hit different it's
your birthday it's your birthday it's
the birthday birthday
boy birthday boy bless what I like Halo
has done a better job like I do think
they still the difference that they're
going to have a hard time competing with
someone like fortnite even the finals
because I feel like that's going to be a
very dominant brand in the industry is
there they still have to keep to some
remnants of what makes sense in the
aesthetic pleasing of of Halo like
fortnite like we'll put anime characters
and not only we put an characters we can
make them suckers look like anime
characters like they don't there'll be
like you'll be fighting like six
different people in one game of fortnite
and they all have different art styles
crazy and you know fortnite's able to
get away with stuff like that so they
have way they could essentially put
anyone in the game yeah pretty much the
problem with Halo is they take the self
too seriously that's the problem I
remember when they did the cats
everybody had a contion I was like
C I know to be annoying you were
hilarious
cool so it's good man I really enjoy uh
Halo definitely uh pulling out you know
we uh
pause we we got some you stupidy we got
some good stuff coming out this month we
got U infinite wealth coming out this
month oh that's been interesting me me
and King over the break we were uh we
were streaming Boulders Gate 3 I was
playing it today by myself he says it's
boring yeah
shout out shout out to the worst game of
the year I've ever played oh my Lord no
no no no I ain't GNA font SEO has to
take that but the only Reon why the only
reason why SEO has to take that because
I was straight trash so so C out that
one out that let's C out that let's keep
second on Buck it's probably the
greatest game ever I'm just the absolute
worst Soul player okay fa up fa up that
that right there but beautiful game I
was sneak it was fun until I got to the
first guy and the first guy just kept
killing me over I said hell that yeah
the regular enemies are F the rest n the
rest of game not but that I was playing
Boulders gate today I said you know what
you know cuz back in the days when you
were sick as a kid that was your time to
play you know I I don't know what codes
we had back then but our codes allowed
us to play games these codes nowadays be
like you better watch some Netflix you
better set
up to your nose and cut this out so I'm
playing Boulders gate today tell me why
had to do all the stuff me and adct did
already yeah yeah cuz you did the
multiplayer and you had to bring your
your man over there and then yeah yeah
yeah we're talking about going lie uh I
let Grace pick my character and I'm
regretting that oh yeah he got a nice he
got a nice woman character is nice yeah
I'm regretting that got I like your
there not even that like
inbalance B his bosoms in his hips was
dope my stuff is like unbalanced like
I'm a rogue that has ice breath like
what like you got I chose to do that wow
my character you should see my character
in The playthrough I'm doing with K and
K and
them see that's a barbarian that's
that's that's a real character and of
course joining us in progress on the
Glorious birthday week was our most
technical ging Lord the solo game list
for the single player selfish experience
and also the
sadus the Lord of crown and Messiah or
something
and the
I PC races oh l s how we doing sir I'm
good happy New Year everyone what's
going ony birthday sir happy birthday
did you get the gift that um these guys
sent you who sent me who's these oh n i
what are you talk
about I have not received anything oh
play with my joy
I have not received no no
FY fa
activity none of that
sir oh man but thank you for all the
well wishes online that's I like to be
lowkey on my birthday because usually
we're still off and the same thing like
and I um forgot how it came up that he
was like when's my birthday or whatever
oh because I had to tell you guys that
my sister had gifted me tickets for the
day and King was like yo when's your
birthday I'm like today see the problem
with him is I'm I'm the worst with
people's dates right except except for
Cog except for CG's date because Cog
date kind of Xbox
datebox it is Xbox day is kind of funny
but the thing is Sovereign Online on
Facebook he don't have a face he don't
have a date he don't have nothing the
most ninja is Ninja on social media
Facebook you really snitches it out and
it goes to my phone and to be like yo
it's today's addict's birthday and I can
I can act like I know I remember
Facebook be helping yeah it a going
front it be helping so when his birthday
pop up I I I feel so bad cuz I be like I
don't remember how you going to be
friends and brothers with somebody for
almost 30 years and be like I don't know
his birthday see I know everybody's
birthday cuz I deal with with the travel
stuff and all that stuff so I have it I
have it oh yeah yeah but I appreciate
y'all that was a beautiful thing
everybody that sent out well wishes as
well thank you so much I hope I got I
said Thank you to everybody but yeah it
was uh it wasn't this restful break as I
would have liked it to be because I I
didn't have the fulltime off I had to
work one of my jobs so so I had but a
couple days here and there um what did I
manage to do so I managed to I finished
I finished 2023 game uh God of War
Ragnarok oh all right
oh so just to just to clarify real quick
uh do you see where I like back then
when I was talking about like the ending
was disappointing or did you feel a
different way because I was disappointed
it was low I mean I would say that the
that the uh the Whatchamacallit the the
grand moments like the fights the the
the those moments yeah were the
cinematics were amazing I think at the
end at the end the cinematics were
amazing no and I mean even cinematics
within fight set pieces were good set
pieces were quick time events no it
wasn't quick time the set pieces were
great I just think ultimately the way it
the way it finished was like it wasn't
like anticlimactic yeah like oh oh so
this is cuz this is the thing right you
go into this why you know all the
descrip words for what's bad what's bad
he has it right on the tip of pause I
ain't got nothing on the tip of my
tongue do ready so it it was sort of
anticlimactic and the thing is when I
looked at it as a package when I when it
finished I was like you know what it is
like you go in you're like Ragnarok is
gonna be this crazy crazy thing and when
you go in obviously it's a game they
have to figure out how to you know kind
of squeeze it down into a game so
ultimately what what turned out to be
Ragnarok was basically like one like
like you running down you you running up
on a Asgard trying to roll up in there
you you get at you you have to get at uh
what at what youall it what the heck is
his name OD Odin God why am I forgetting
these people's name It Whack and that
was that's that's pretty much it
like set pieces what I didn't like is
you know spoiler alert you you you go
and get this all right my headphone off
yeah I I DN sure whack if you ain't
played
it so what I didn't like is is you know
you get this quote unquote something to
help fight in the end and that sucker
was mad useless like I feel like you
wasted a good portion of the game
getting this machine this fight and then
when it came down to using it that's it
like that was it yeah it was very quick
it was very like I felt like the last
like two hours of that game was highly
rushed yeah yeah it really did feel that
way again me G me huge Kingdom Hearts 3
Vibes I expected because obviously if
you know the story of what Ragnarok is
is all of the sort of all the all of the
different Realms coming together oh we
done destroying this game all the
PlayStation you know they don't play
games so
they didn't quite do that there was
things like oh this realm is on the way
on its way to the fight nah it's not
happening so they shut down the like
whole Realms joining the fight so they
didn't have so they didn't have to
animate all of that so I was a little
disappointed in that you gonna get that
in the next
one but ultimately I I enjoyed it I
played it over God knows how many years
that's how long it took me to beat it
and I played some of the Val Hall I was
about to ask you yeah how's the Val Hall
I I like that cuz I again the Rog light
aspect of
of it fits it well right cuz all the
different weapons and permutations of of
of how you can set up your your cradles
for combat it works with that um and
story-wise some cool things again don't
want to spoil the end of it at the at
the end of the game it it kind of shows
you a path forward right how how can we
go forward and it's something that that
Kratos uh sort of sees that kind of
indicates a possible path for him and
this sort of expands upon that and then
while still going back and giving you
know old school fans King a little bit
of fan service all right all
right yeah got his attention they did
something for for us people they did
something kind of for you kind of for
you uh kind kind of kind of but uh yeah
I I enjoyed it I'll play more Valla and
try to finish that out and see see how
that is that's what's up uh what else I
ain't playing much else of anything else
a little bit of field yeah but you know
for me that's good wait you threw
sofield back on I threw it back on cuz I
hadn't touched it in at a minute can we
advance the main story that's what I've
been trying to do oh okay cuz I know you
haven't touched like any of the
constellation I have like 110 hours in
next done that that the best parts I'm
like yo could you get on the story you
know what it is the we didn't know that
going in Des you playing it like old
school I'mma Be Real it's cool how they
handled New Game Plus but I think people
exaggerate that okay but I'm just
talking about the story yeah you said
that a lot you on like five new game
pluses though right I'm on the second I
I didn't okay do to get the second and
third quests of the story going to tell
you where I'm at yes I just got
Kaiser wow okay okay Jesus okay yeah
yeah you got please so you're you're
essentially at the beginning of the yeah
like he just he just jumped out the ship
and just went off on his own listen I
got that code I was like yep I as soon
as I walked out of that first after that
first to go right I'm in the Vanguard
believe oh at least you did the you
started the vard oh God thank you at
least you did one he said I believe I
believe yeah well they taught you how to
to fly the ship rightly ship okay cool
cool cool that that's actually good did
you go to the first mission in the
Vanguard yet did you go to
tetti I believe I did yes okay but again
I stopped playing for so long I you know
about the teror you know about the ter
oh yeah no so this is the Kaiser thing
is about the terramorph yeah okay so you
got the okay okay yeah so yeah no I know
about all that um but you know funny I
technically it got spoiled for me but I
technically haven't gotten to the oish
moment in the game where you're like you
discover something about yourself I'm
like everybody's like how did you miss
that I'm like I I a go there bro I was
running around to these planets and try
to see things so okay I did a little bit
of that you know what I did I threw on
my uh 3DS wow I had a I had a hankering
to play out run
oh and the thing is that WDS right got
rip the 3DS because you can't even buy
anything on that that store anymore but
uh right before I had uh downloaded all
the stuff that I had like for whatever
reason my past 3DS I had you know
Nintendo accounts are crazy so I had to
redownload them um and if you guys
remember on the 3DS there were a bunch
of Sega Classics that were made in 3D
and it is the only place you can play
them in 3D yeah so bro I th that outrun
on mind you it's arcade outrun it's not
home out run it's arcade outrun in 3
yeah oh my God it's and the the sad part
is like I'm a huge Zelda fan and like
you could only play like the 3D remakes
of um Ocarina time and maj's mask on
that like what you're playing on the the
switch is essentially the the
N64 emulation at at some point they'll
charge you and they'll do the work and
pass it they'll do that it's rumored
that the switch 2 is going to launch
with an aaran of time remake I hope so I
like
so um yeah for you guys that don't know
unfortunately so my sister got me
tickets for a Broadway show today after
I told her hey you know I have the show
on Sunday she was like okay cool yeah by
the way the show we're going to us on
Sunday I was like oh okay yeah so we
know your time's limited yes I am out of
here in five minutes so just my
apologies uh I don't know if you guys
want to just adct wanted wanted me to
chime in on something yeah let's get you
let's get your charm in let's get your
charm in because um what we need you to
do for the uh the obviously and samc
leaks you know two two aspects first I
was going to break it down is one the
ethical aspect of it and then two the
leaks themselves what did you feel you
know about them what did you learn what
did you discover what was the most
surprising thing um okay for the leaks
themselves because again I tried to stay
as blind as possible on that stuff
because I don't want to spoil the game
for myself I don't want to spoil who's
in the game I don't want to spoil
necessarily gaml so I saw like two
screenshots and a little bit of
pre-alpha footage that they just kind of
showed traversal bit and that's all I
saw and I was like I'm good that's it I
don't need to see anything else I all
yeah so I don't know cuz I know within
that they had like the breakdown of the
story throughout the game I didn't want
to know any of that did you see any the
um the financial stuff the did you see
the okay the big business PlayStation
the big broad Xbox relationship stuff
yes the stuff the hey we may we we may
be in the lead in some ways but this we
need to be fearful of what's going on
over here and let's not be stupid cuz we
are a business you know if we go to
sleep on our competitor this is not good
so uh you know business stuff yes and
that stuff um so again that's all I
pretty much got into when it came to the
leaks of of game information and stuff
like that so you found out that they
broke yeah they're spending a whole lot
of money I I love how they every y'all
walk around stuff they don't say the
truth you found out that they
broke so anyway uh what another thing
that was a little bit disappointing to
me was the fact that they are like
they're the Marvel Factory now they
really are now I I will say this been
saying for call yeah this is the thing
though right as much as those games cost
to make I don't blame Marvel for getting
into bed with the company that's shown
they can do it do it yeah you know what
I mean so I and then I don't blame for
taking a bag it's a
Marv got them and and but this is the
thing as well right and I I seen some of
the the Fanboy conversation back and
forth is like well all right okay blade
is cool I love blade I'm I'm hoping
that's an amazing game right blade is
not Spider-Man blade oh they try to act
like it's going the sa they getting they
getting they getting the second tier
character that's a second tier street
level Street Lev character and then you
get on top of that we obviously know the
X-Men is coming right so so they again
they're trusting insomniac with they top
of the top um and they again I don't
blame them either they saw what happened
when they gave Crystal Dynamics Avengers
they don't want to have that happen
again if you have a team that you know
can do a good job has a good sense of
what they want to do with these
characters I don't blame them and I
don't blame Insomniac for taking that
back it is a little bit you know when
you look at the breakdown yes there will
be another Ratchet and Clank yes they're
talking about another new IP even though
it didn't make any money even though it
made zero money which is crazy Z money
is zero cents yeah and that that sucks
cuz you you I know you love that game
and I love that I love it to death but I
know the PlayStation dudes don't buy it
yeah that unfortunately it's not it
ain't that um so that all that said um
all of the moral conversation around
covering it or not covering it um I
think it's BS I think it's hypocrisy I
think it was an opportunity for and I
and I'll say the name because it was the
name that was most circulated obviously
kind of funny in Greg Miller in his
statement and kind of everybody
gravitating to that and and my thing is
this I don't begrudge I don't think of
any of these guys as journalists anymore
pure journalists right you're not you're
not you you know Greg Miller has a big
ass company that he has to run and
maintain you know they still have a lot
of advertisements they still have a lot
of promotional stuff they do they have
to make money they have to make money so
in saying that you know that your your
relationships with these companies now
are different you you you you kind of
one one one hand washes the other is one
of those type of things and for him to
keep getting the access that he gets and
things of that nature the relationship
is not different I would argue that you
know in any sort of journalistic
relationship in in relation to the news
you're covering the relationship should
be somewhat adversarial almost like it's
like you're not supposed to be in love
with the thing you're covering right but
in games it's always been sort of
different the enthusiasts are the
journalists and you try to draw that
line when you stop being a journalist
and you're a content creator and you
have your own company I get it that line
is blurred already all of that said all
he needed to do was be honest about
instead of creating a moral Soap Box to
stand on and say no this is objectively
wrong we're not going to cover this
because it's objectively wrong having
covered the Capcom the steam leaks the
uh what the the GTA leaks Xbox whole
road map yeah the whole road map where
was where was the moral High Ground
there no there was none because
again you have relationships with these
people on the dev side and even more
over I can see the fear of Sony being
like yo what are you doing play with Rel
Sony don't play with that right so I I I
get it be honest about it don't create a
moral High Ground so that you look like
you're above everybody and you're taking
this this you're taking this stance that
this is this is unethical when it's
you're in the game bro I understand like
I understand all you need to do is be
honest about just say yo you know what
sports win the game yeah just say you
know look we're too close to situation
we guys Toc we refuse to cover it
because of our ship and that and that be
that I actually respected that I would I
would have respected it hey you know
what be honest like yo
listen dude he just came out and laughed
and said I'm in the game bro I'm not not
the EA yeah and and that is it but this
this this moral High Ground that he
created and then at on top of it making
it seem like if you don't follow suit
with that you're in the wrong for
talking about this that was my issue
because I felt like they were trying to
not necessarily maybe not their
intentions but to me when I was looking
at the situation and the way it was laid
out it felt like they were trying to
push the industry in that direction that
was his intention you can't say he try
not to
to me when I'm looking at this I'm like
look like I'm sure these PR people would
love to start you know penalizing people
for covering leaks and stuff because
that makes their life a living hell when
stuff gets leaked so if they know if
anything gets leaked no one's ever going
to talk about it then I'm sure they
would love that and it's just like look
at the end of the day like how often do
we talk about leaks on this podcast not
often a lot just have better security
bro yeah and then this idea that it's
like oh King not wrong like why should
we get punished and penalized
for for not for someone else not being
able to uphold their job and I get that
that that section's hard to do but it's
like it's it's not my fault like I'm not
covering stuff I'm not supposed to be in
covering you know people are saying oh
you know with the leaked information no
one was covering that no one was even
talking about that talking about to you
have to be the lowest of the low to be
like hey I can't cover this information
unless I talk about you know Yuri
lenthal social security number some
passp what like who know like if you're
doing that then you don't belong in the
space you're just a troll and you're
just looking for clicks and you don't
belong in the space nobody nobody worth
this salt doing having done this for
years already is going to do that you're
going to talk about the newsworthy stuff
the stuff that matters to the greater
scope of how this industry works yeah
people being able to play Wolverine
right now that that's what we talk
about you know what like right if they
would have just came out and I think
everyone would agre some people would
have still jab put Jabs in Greg but if
you said yo we too close to the
situation uh we're just stepping out for
this particular leag people say okay I
get it but the fact that they went the
direction they went knowing they've
covered previous leagues made it look
like oh so you bought that's L literally
what it made it look like so do you work
for Insomniac because you cover everyone
else and I and it's the thing oh you're
trying to get brought either you brought
or you trying to get brought like said I
don't begrudge them that because again
as big as this company is you got a
studio to maintain you got you got uh
employees to pay you have a lot of
expenses so when you see and I'm sure
that patreon is very large right but
that that's not enough they have all
they still do advertisements they still
do promo deals he still does hosting
gigs and stuff to that matter that I'm
sure in some way here per him goes back
to kind of funny you got to do what you
got to do to to to to support the
company that you've built 100%
understand that appreciate that we as
somebody we you look at all this look at
all the stuff that we do right this it's
the nature of the game that's the
business absolutely be honest I don't
know how you look you look at your
audience dead in the face and think
they're so stupid that they're going to
buy this and then some people do buy it
as oh this is this is a moral thing that
I need to do um and it's like no that's
that is not the case another thing that
bothers me about that space and I'll
leave you with that cuz I'm already late
um I didn't want to ask you about two
other things um it just no I'm not going
to mention this because it mentions
somebody specific
give me give me the full B I say your
name I'll just get out there with K's
like let me have your
homework yeah Xbox next 2026 yay you for
it no see I'm a nay and I tell you this
why a lot of people see this as the Xbox
360 moment get out ahead of the company
get out ahead of your competition beat
them to the punch you we at a point
where Graphics the jump isn't that crazy
and if it's some hybrid model it still
be super powerful I you see the 360
moment right pessimist in me sees the
Dreamcast
moment and I'm like you get out and it
and if you know if PlayStation decides
to bump up their timeline a little bit
and maybe you're out in the market a
year year and a half instead of two or
two plus over a sudden the next Xbox
looks like a midst step half step in the
way the dream pass was okay okay and
it's that's what worries me okay it is
like the 360 moment couldn't I mean they
couldn't have planned it better right
because it's like the the the
PlayStation wasn't ready it was super
expensive it would have been more
expensive if they tried to launch it day
and date with the 360 right um so it
would it would work perfectly for them
but I just I'm worried that because no
need to jump out the window you don't
need to jump out the window and I it
it's just one of those things like man
PlayStation when it comes to that sort
of area of just like console sales uh
mind share stuff like that it especially
launching at the same time or or sorry
launch you know if they decide to launch
close to you I just I can see it
backfire in a way that that worries me
interesting interesting if it's not 100%
ready because again the original
timeline was 2028 so how you going to
tell me you get to get something out
comparable right well that's the concern
earlier right that's the concern so
that's my worry bro no I get it they
didn't predict for that no they didn't
predict for what happened there like oh
well this fell in my lap well this
accelerated our timeline by two years
yeah we'll see Xbox we'll see XBox
exclusive potentially multiplat the
rumors are high-fi Rush going to switch
that makes that makes the most sense
it's it's the one that obviously runs
well on the I think would run well on
the switch no problem with the messaging
for you no problem with with that's with
the backlash people are very upset well
this goes back this goes back to what I
listen I
listen the I Love Phil love the team
this
talk SL SL they they tell you what you
want to hear you meaning the crazy
people they tell you what they want to
hear so you don't kill them in the
moment when they tell you the truth and
they're going to disseminate the truth
in little bits and pieces like this
without having to you know slap you in
the face with it like yes every
opportunity we have to go third party we
will do that because we we want game
pass to be a platform MH that's just the
fact of the matter is they're GNA keep
telling you guys and giving you guys a
console as long as they possibly can at
some point that statement is not going
to be true and because they want game
pass to be the platform and in order
yeah after PlayStation dies then they
can stop soever that it's just you first
but they're not going to you know we saw
it before with aie right and and things
like that even though that wasn't that
wasn't that wasn't first he fail doin
said that that was a mistake and that um
you know they don't plan on doing that
again I don't know why was it a mistake
I don't think the number said it was a
mistake I mean there was it was I'm just
telling you what the man say that's what
and that goes back to I'm telling you
what you want to hear right now so you
don't kill me and I know my audience I
know what I need to say to them so they
don't you know have pitchforks at the
gates I get it that's that is so again
this is guys this is GNA happen more and
more by little it's gonna happen more
and more because again Xbox wants to be
this all-encompassing thing Game Pass
they want it to be this all-encompassing
thing as long as they possibly can give
give you a console they will because
they know that's what y'all want right
but but where it makes sense they are
going to put these games on other
platforms where where where the there's
a willingness for it to happen obviously
they have that closer relationship with
Nintendo that they have with PlayStation
um but I wouldn't put it past appearing
on Playstation time I know you gotta go
I you got go but have fun have a great
have a great birthday the chat demand
even though he has to go they said if he
could just read play Let's play with
other's joysticks before you leave to
hear your glorious voice before you and
let's play with each other's joysticks
10 super chat dear sa I wrote you but
you still ain't calling I left myell my
pager my home phone at the bottom wow
you must have missed my birthday package
but my year has finally started now that
I have
seen and D thank you for apprciate
you all right I love y my
sister enjoy happy day love you gonna go
see Sweeny Tod we seeing Sweeney Tod
today what's up no doubt no doubt peace
peace peace you already know all right
cool uh K we do the intro I don't think
I know don't worry about that let's go
get it let's go get it my intro all
right and of course we have the
incredible hul of this aka the EXs gamer
the prophit of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the Xbox front line movement
ooh belov it Lord King how we doing sir
I'm doing great I'm feeling like C
Williams out here I'm feeling like C
Williams all
thiss oh man all these frauds out here
boy I've been exposing these frauds for
years and finally dudes is catching up
yo I G like to expose a lot of you
frauds cuz now you're like yeah Mike
your Michael paor said that Xbox game
passes I've been telling you that fa
I've been telling you your PlayStation
was out fa but y'all wait for the next
dude to tell you
why why cuz y'all need to have a
different face tell you oh oh we doing
that same words that's telling you come
on cat I've been telling you for a
million but but but y'all need some a
certain type of face to tell
you till you catch it
right how about if that dude just
listening to all the stuff that I said
what I'm
saying cuz it do be sounding like it and
it do be feeling like it said that then
they come out and they say it y'all be
like
word word he on to something n they you
get your flow was still kick him off
yeah the real rights do my real rights
do 6K strong dude that's on Xbox front
line y'all do they taking something a
little long to catch up yeah yeah but
you monkey mouth dudes I'm telling you
dudes right now man we on your head man
pause all right we on your head now
pause 2024 we coming for everything
that's been promised and everything that
we want I told you they out paperwork
showed you they are I told you they
don't make no bread paperwork showed you
all these dudes remember all the little
generals talking all that stuff we buy
games we I told you they
didn't I told you all that we got 50
million so 50 million so but you don't
buy games that's like selling cars
without buying the insurance yo you will
not be able to hold that lot that lot
Ain't Gonna Stand they make Sony makes
money off of games they don't make money
off of consoles so every time y'all post
up yo we they sold 50 million that's a l
that's a absolute L we're beating y'all
three to one but how come our bread look
the same like it don't make sense right
so make it make sense either y'all don't
know math or Y don't understand how to
add and subtract properly but I'mma tell
you this I'mma tell you this
2024 y'all G to see by the end of this
what y really smell like it's going to I
can't wait till the finan in March
that's all I got to say when Jim leave
when when Jim leave watch when Jim walk
out the door soon as Jim Clos the door
he ain't goingon to be around that day
he going to close the door that day yall
going to see exactly where they at they
at the bottom of the barrel looking up
at everybody else and y'all going to be
like but we was nice though y'all was
nice damn homie and high school you was
the man
homie everborn I got you today we gonna
get to that topic for sure okay okay but
I'm feeling like Cat Williams out here
there okay you feel like cat I'm feeling
like cat but I've been playing bers gate
with my sickness yes oh man I just got
over my cold wifey comes home and you
know she works with children so you know
children codes are crazy CP yeah so she
came home with some bubonic chronic Bo
bubic she she laid up in the bed and she
coughed and she coughed in a way that
I've never heard her cough before and I
and my brain said you going to get sick
I got up went to work came back and I
listen I got your stuff in the car so
all those people that did get at me um I
got the statue in the car I got my
father's package in the car and I got
some coins in the car for people that
did get at me for their coins
right that
Friday I did not get out of this house I
was supposed to do video do Xbox front
line I couldn't get off my bed boy it's
real bro season is crazy bro no so so K
and I was talking and he going down on
his end pause I'm going down on my end
wild that was wild the ends and all that
make don't don't make me laugh don't
make me laugh I know laugh heard soon as
you laugh that's what all the chest yeah
I got you I got you yeah yeah so so yo
so we talking about that part but I
wasn't able to give y'all a show and I
said all right you know what satday I
can do it shout out to adct for calling
me he was like yo are you okay whatever
and you know his his call adct has many
measures to his calls are you okay oh
we're going to do this do you have a
video going up but he doesn't have to
say all of that and then you know I'm
like n I'm I'm not able to go I am not
able but I'm feeling a little bit better
he's like all right cool I'm just
checking in on you everything's good so
I love this dude I'm telling you right
now if y'all don't got a attic in your
life you better go find
one get yourself an attic in your life
get yourself an attic in your life
but he checked up on me and then um I
was just trying to get better for today
to be honest with you because I did not
want to miss today return yeah yeah so
that's all i' been doing and I was
trying to play Boulders gate and I feel
him with the Starfield because I had
jumped inside Starfield and I was like
what the hell was I doing like you know
how we get back to a space he was like
I'm you don't remember what why was I
here why why am I here and and I can't
go by the call log to see like you know
the story log because I don't play by
the story oh Lord my joint is I want to
steal ship so I think maybe I was there
for to steal a ship and then then the
ship is gone so I got to find something
else to do but now my thing is going to
collect all the powers so wherever the
notes tell me so yeah I go to see Paris
in the space station oh yo you
stupid like I'm be like hey Paris
I up Paris I go I swear to God he look
like Paris yeah I'll be like yo what's
up Paris what I got to do like y there's
another dude over at another Zol system
let me go over to the Zola and I go over
there and get their powers but yeah um
some of some of the powers I don't use
in battle some of the some of the powers
I do use but it's um it's fun I'm still
getting I'm I'm still not at that point
where
mhm the story has taken a a turn for me
because I haven't played story like I
listen to y'all and this is the greatest
story for y'all but I'm it's so much to
do you've done nothing now now get back
to the story You' been you've been
months of doing nothing now please just
put the quest marker on the
constellation missions and do it trust
me your life will change it will be a
different experience for you just just
just start just stop just play the game
the way you want to King he did that for
that clearly he's not done anything
clearly but robbing people and doing
ships and all this other stuff but I got
13 ships got that's awesome please start
the story sir I can't sell I can't sell
none of them though yeah because you got
to register and all that pay money to
register and all ton of money yo shout
out to Todd for being smart on that yeah
he knew was like we we ain't GNA let you
be all felonius we gonna have to
register we know you don't got the bread
for this so yeah yeah shout out to him
but n that's what I've been doing
Boulders gate and that oh and the fact
that so far for me
mhm but I see it being Game of the Year
you understand like it's so far for me
it's not okay but I'm so early on and
and I can see it being game of the year
because the role of the dice changes the
game oh you talk about yeah yeah a
million times like because you can roll
it and it be like Nate and then it go
another way so everybody's game play is
going to be unique and then it's the the
the the the level of conversation that
you have with it like some people are
not going to pick certain things that
you will pick like you know
possibilities is crazy right so it's
it's like it feels like it's endless
it's not really but it gives you the the
illusion that it's endless endless
possibilities and I did one thing that I
didn't do before and I made sure I
didn't do it on purpose to see if I was
able to get out the ship without doing
that one little storyline okay I did and
I was like man that girl must have died
there so I was like that's crazy because
if if you if you go do that yeah you see
something totally different right so I I
can see how people can say that it's
game of the year it has a ton of load
screens yeah a lot loading lot load I
want I want the next consoles to have a
real fast
SSD I mean a real joint like so
hopefully the next consoles will have a
faster SSD but yeah I know it's it's
dope and of course finally myself I can
talk about
me the G did himself the Shinobi Lord
Cognito spread that real in the RP not
tell you what you want to he what you
need to hear shout out to Mr M play
Shout out to FR Duke we talk about Xbox
next which we will talk about um shout
out to e t out Travis talking that
Destiny talk what's going on and uh a
lot of people not feeling a witness
right now we're going to get into that
later as far as what's going on with
that storyline and obviously after have
to wrap up all final shape as far as
what I've been playing surprisingly call
of Duty Call of Duty the campaign um I
don't know how long I am start you
playing you playing the campaign I am
playing now look disclosure I have not
played a Call of Duty in over over a
decade but tell me it look dope though
right I ain't going call me casual
Co but this look fire to me look fire
right like I'm sitting I'm like yo we
storming the beach I mean not storming
the beach yo we prison we under yo we we
we going down the ropes we first we
scaled The Joint I what I liked is the
production value I was like yo this is
this is boovie they outside with it
right so I I don't know that this is
reused assets so I don't know what's
going right I'm like this look great it
feels epic then they got the Russian
military dude you break them out you we
going through that dude a yo he a he's
not ill with it he ill with it and he's
like killer yo so I'm sitting here I'm
like all right then the next mission we
was like all right they they I'm some
chick on the other side and it was the
stealth with with the crates and you yo
we got to we got to play stealth and I'm
like this is fire to be call me
Antiquated but I was having fun so I'm
going to I'm going to end it and then
I'll make my final decision to see you
know if it's Justified cuz it's just way
too so make question I question did you
get to the the part where the gas leak I
think that's where I'm at now I think so
you okay after you finish the gas leap
joint yeah I ain't going to front Jo
that's when I'm went on my rant what the
hell these dudes to talk about I'm like
I I like it like what is so bad about
this but hey I'm not the dud there
that's there every year so maybe the
guys every year they like nah son they
use that in ' 88 over here then they use
that in '99 so they just remix the remix
all right maybe that's fine I'm just
talking about from my experience for
someone who's not played Call of Duty at
all in years I was like this is fun but
okay whatever it is what it is I didn't
I didn't think it was the worst thing
I've ever played at all at all so yo and
listen let me tell you something my son
plays my my middle son he plays Call of
Duty every day like every day I said you
don't play anything else it got to a
point where I'm so sick and tired of him
playing it yeah and like I'm like I do
this with fortnite but I'm like yo bro
come down now are you going to play
something else he's like n n n this is
where we at we got my Squad we got my
team so it has so many different lay
single player dudes and then the
multiplayer dudes is rabbit with it yeah
it is what it is people say war is where
it's at though so it is it is what it is
that's what he's playing he's playing
War obviously balers gate with adct and
sin and the crew absolutely hilarious
y'all saw my man I got the L beefy
situation going on yo we got to play
whatam call it together a little demo
bro yeah yeah we got to get the demo
together that's we got pick a day we got
to do the Dem so that's that um and I
started uh Persona 5 tactica um which I
thought was really cool I heard that's
leaving out of Game Pass not tactica
just got there not tactica it's the
other one one of other yeah Royale left
Royale left and for's about to leave
yeah Royale left big cloud what's going
on Sinister what up um yeah so basically
n they joint is fire they just I'm with
addict though they talk too much between
every little thing and I'm just like bro
I just want to get to the next mission
can I get to the next I don't mind
talking just make it make it
entertaining yeah it's just like they
want you to read so much text and yay
guys and we did this and why are we here
and why does this coffee shop look like
the same coffee and it's like yo all
right cool cool cool let's go you know
what I'm saying and that's the thing now
the beginning is explaining the
mechanics and stuff like that don't get
me wrong the turn blades gameplay is is
fire I do like it there's some cool
little Mechanics for all three of y'all
but it's actually pretty challenging
it's not as easy as you would think it
would be but uh I I'm Still Rock with it
for a little bit longer I'll see if it
kind of get intensifies more for me so I
pulled through and beat it oh you pulled
through okay cool yeah that's what I was
fig but I do like it the gamepl is is
cool and and and and they got a lot of
core Persona like you can fusee the
personas you they got a lot of the Core
Essence Persona stuff in it so I was
like all right cool so I think it's a
good get for turn base guys and then
last was uh Dy season of The Wish shout
out to S and them we've been rocking um
the new dungeon and and and I believe
the new exotic mission was is very cool
and uh yeah that's prettyy much that let
for get a couple of super chats I mean
AD I'm going need some help with these
because obviously our man's is gone but
um we got what we got got um we got a
seven month member trap from Don talku
shout out to the IOP glad to be back in
the realm after our break Sundays ain't
been the same without you trap from
Mexican zberg will 2024 be the year that
atct starts mispronouncing idals IDs
nope n got welcome to Golden Arena PR I
put some uh put put some Crest in the
chat for him yeah yeah we got a 10 super
chat from Michael Mooney mhm uh if first
party Xbox has coming to Playstation
then contract uh then the contract must
have been adjusted by Sony so what did
Sony give up I don't know hold on let me
shout out Andy Cruz he didn't switch out
he say especially the missions yes in
Persona time the missions where you only
have one turn them side quest missions
is wild crazy hate those missions
continue I actually like those those are
really challenging I man they're
challenging
continue yeah
um shout out to uh Cedric H member for
42 months next time say something my
dude uh Deo D with uh welcome to the
bronze he he uh put some logos in the
chat we got $10 chat from Robert kellet
bless day Lords 2023 was a huge year for
me and you guys giving me a chance on
loget was a highlight for me made 2024
bring health and wealth good games and
more Antics from you guys we got a
salute Rob
Michael cherlo that's what you're
getting from me we're moving on welcome
to Lord silver uh shout out to uh uh
decado he gifted 10 IOP memberships oh
wow salute shout out to him we got F out
super chat from uh Karma God 91 King
Messiah young wolf and Lord Arby's
welcome back lord
2024 iron Lords breeding the son every
Sunday y'all uh love y'all brothers Xbox
Advance the Line2 trip from the Casual
new gamer uh watching football and
listening to the iron Lords uh you know
one of those you're definitely doing
correctly U welcome to uh to the
membership uh om War I think is the way
he wants that I don't know who
cares from har and D I already told
people you you it is what it is $2 TR
from Harvard Inga
Happy New Year's here's to a great
year uh we got a okay we got you I'm
already on to the next one yes we got a
50 Super Chat from daram har
thread me Doc I want that Cog beef
doctor you mean that third leg package
me facts
wow yo yo
[Music]
Yoo
back to you addict we got a $2 for the
long by the way they never fixed my
joint y'all they never did they never
did he a call us long house gaming
welcome back Lords black Viking what's
up man oh salute black Viking yo shout
out to Black Viking if y'all not uh Sub
sub to his Channel please sub to his
channel he's out here doing the realness
it's what's up I like his channel the
realness you need to go into your
settings King and click that you have a
green screen because you are you're
you're the stuff is clipping really
really bad super trat from Nelson River
happy birthday Lord Sol today's also my
birthday just got a foot of snow it's
snowing like crazy where am snow now uh
but today is all about the Lords and
football can't ask for a better day it's
all about the Lord I don't know about
that
football it's all about the Lord we got
uh Craig hooligan gifted one IOP
membership definitely put some uh some
logos in the chat we got a$3 Super Chat
from legendary Yi # peace love life to
the Lord stay legendary salute Y2 Super
Chat from Arthur Harris happy New Year
Xbox 2024 let's go IOP let's go I am not
reading that because I saw $5 super from
Andre doly happy New Year y'all and uh
and the new Xbox PC hybrid is going away
from sock and giving us medium to ultra
settings for like traditional PC k
# no PlayStation 6 okay okay facts Jonas
the dad with the uh to two membership uh
uh two month membership chat uh PS is a
stripper all teas no please and you
still paying for it hash Hold the Line
hit that like button hit that like
button hit that like but that like
button please we got we got a $2 Che
from MC 20 2 third 54 I don't know maybe
that's a street address Happy New Year's
Lord King
uh we got uh a member chat from Geek to
sneak he's been a member for two months
what's good people hope everyone is
doing well we got a $6 Super Chat cuz
I'm adding all them together man saying
all together the same thing pathetic
Port begging ponies got no games # no
ps6 pathetic Port begging ponies got no
games we don't have to read it three
times ps6 he said said it three times
you combined it and that's what got no
games # ps6 oh my God it jumped okay
then dado with the 10 gifted memberships
that's 20 he's gifted this podcast would
appreciate but the but the we got 20 new
members I expect some some crazy amounts
of logos in that chat we need some C in
that
chat you can go now okay face uh 23 bkny
$100 Super Chat thank you GTA 6 will be
the biggest game of the Gen Sony will
have marketing rights and will advertise
play the best version of GTA 6 on PS5
Pro big push with console sales and GTA6
will sellable on Playstation cuz XBox
guys going to wait five years to GTA 6
is in is in Game Pass King what if they
don't that part we already know they
don't got money to get nothing so what
if they don't get the market right what
if Microsoft actually gets the marketing
R what happens then what what really
goes down for you now like y'all already
got to pay back that money to uh for to
to Disney that's that's 230 million off
the rip y'all ain't even selling game
yet we we playing Wolverine right now
please sit down you ridiculous JD G5
Super Chat oh here we go pathetic Port
begging ponies Got No Game No games last
year no games this year probably no
games next year message the pony stop
part beging all right for for is a
legend remember 48 months he said um Cog
the end to like the end to like a dragon
the man that would eras his name was
fire excited for infinite wealth on God
yeah that joint is crazy very much very
powerful yeah we um hopefully we might
be getting a review copy of uh infinite
well so we might have a lot of coverage
for that game yeah man David hot rght
remember for 26 months glad to have the
Lords back let's keep crushing it in
2024 yes sir masokista $5 Super Chat we
know the journalists are in bed with
Sony it was proven the Xbox tax is real
and U Modern Warfare three got low
scores because it's an Xbox game now
love y'all SM wild smiley face Gerald
Mack OG member for 38 months happy New
Year or Hell the ILP salute the ls ashra
beards # weed them boys we outside Xbox
world order it's fully operational jald
Mac you need to hit me in the DMS on
Twitter and stop it you won oh okay all
right yeah what's up apparently we're
having buffering issues okay you just
YouTube bugging out just let it stay
stabiliz guys I promise you it stabilize
dado gifted 10 ump membership salute to
him big cloud the homie l n see y'all at
PX yes sir yes sir I think we are now
caught up on that yep they say people
all buffer let me check the stream stra
just to make sure everything's good on
yeah excellent yeah excellent people
compare me to reforge calm down guys I
do the the mispronouncing thing at this
point cuz it's it's it's an inside joke
you guys uh calm down with that all
right last $5 the Super Chat from David
Hornsby yes watching while working in a
bakery in
Australia that's what up why why are we
going into the fin from suu Sage good
good day lence Starfield ended up being
every bit as big and as good as a game
as they feared the impact it had is
clear to see yeah definitely that that
steam revenue for sure for sure get
setting us up for our our first topic
put in the chat where where you guys are
from where you watching us from I'm
curious on that one super chat for no
please please go go five out super chat
from uh
decado I think missed you guys on the uh
the Choo at the end of the year thanks I
for the excellent content we tried man
we try no doubt no doubt salute salute
um real quick one last pit of bills that
we do have to pay um shout out to again
Lords gaming.net a lot of yall in the
real I seen Robert Kell in there
hopefully Flame the crew Everybody M
mood every you know everybody that do
what they do you know what I'm saying
but I just wanted to give the our
honorary yearly award that we that we
definitely missed cuz we took some time
off and uh this is one brother that
really went above and beyond a
culmination so to speak of all the you
know the writing and scribing ups and
all that stuff for the year man so we
definitely got to present the Scribe the
new scribe of the year for 2023 a person
that we love and respect and he's been
doing it he's been a main state for a
long time and actually be traveling with
us to uh packs East again this year yeah
he went with us last year he went with
us last year for the first time he took
a chance on us man did not know us my
guy right
here he's a younger calmer me yeah the
Young The Young Gun you know what I'm
saying affectionally calls himself the
Michael Jordan the
loget the man really you know again you
can't you can't speak on his work worth
ethic can't speak on his L of Auden
Chronicle you know a man loves some demo
and he he's been to see his growth as
far as a writer and continue to go he
was funny he call josa of world boss as
far as edit which is hilarious but I I
probably present the log net 2023 scribe
of the Year Chris Jones see you nit he
couldn't make it cuz obviously he's got
some personal things going on he will
explain right now but we want to give
him his moment his flowers to see you
init love you brother
congratulations hello Lords and Ladies
of the realm I think sof said he was
going to be gone this week but hello
addict King
Cognito thank you for uh letting me have
a minute thank you very much to the
editors of Lords of gaming.net for
choosing me a scribe of the month I'm
shocked honored humbled and grateful for
that title thanks um sh out special
shout out to the other authors at Lords
of gaming.net incredible work new
article just went up by Lord Eugene
excellent excellent piece on game
preservation check it out and uh shout
out to my wife and
kids to my family still in New York and
to all those who have moved
away grateful for all of you
thanks
all right wait that was a mistake Chris
your Jo for whatever reason they playing
I don't know why my bad brother we gonna
make it right though cuz that was not
that was Lord
lefl that was not Chris so yeah yeah I
don't know why the joint did update in
OBS I think it's just a problem Chris I
see you in there that's all bad we going
to make that right cuz I got the video
the correct video but for whatever
reason it is not playing you can just
screen record it and show it yeah I'm
not doing all that right now it's just
it's it is what it is and we already
late but y I'm sitting there I'm like
like cuz you said that I I said I said
what the hell I
said I said I know seez I'm into this
parallel universe joint I'm like that's
not Chris said I said oh no no that's
not the homie that's not the homie see
you we going make that right so don't
even worry about it and anyway it's
better you come on anyway cuz you still
haven't been on in the realm for real
for real so we going to do that right
the correct way so anyway that's that we
got uh get into these topics no patreon
questions all right cool and then dip
down ain't bother us with patreon
question we ain't killing nobody for the
new year it was it was my fault normally
cuz how I do it is the first IOP of
every month I scheduled the whole month
we're in and when we took that break I
just didn't put it up this week oh okay
yeah no doubt no doubt but I will do
that actually right now cool and uh no
poll because obviously we were away so
we going get on to that so adct you're
up man um Insomniac leaks insomniac
leaks we got to talk about it right a
lot of stuff went down while we were
away um this was the biggest one um I
don't know how you want to attack it
first for the moral aspect about um
covering it not covering it or as as far
as um the leaks themselves it's your
topic I don't think we really have to
talk about the leaks themselves because
you know I don't like to speculate a
whole lot off of information that is
going to be outdated now we could talk
about the general ideal that pretty much
the this game's going yeah you know it
did feel like a little bit of a God of
War last of us together but even that
could change but I do think that's
probably like just the way the game will
move uh you know they'll they'll
redefine everything but I do think it's
going to move generally like the way it
show the game I generally want to talk
about you know do we feel we need to
change how we cover leaks in general
like and I guess there's levels to leaks
you know I feel like all leaks are about
the same I I get that somewh are more
egregious than others but I do feel like
all leaks should be covered around the
same regardless now obviously you know
people say well you know people's
information that is that is a
given and not one time I ever felt like
I needed to elaborate that I'm not going
to share people's leaked
information like I didn't see not one
person talking about that so I feel like
people are just reaching to to stop us
from covering them in general and just
using that as an excuse but you know I I
want to I want to you know that's
generally where I want this conversation
to go so Ken yeah what do you feel about
the um the ethical
portion yeah yeah yeah y'all know it
wasn't even about worry about what Billy
Bob got going on over there with Jane
does here ain't nobody care about that
the the the the the leaks itself showed
a lot of harmful things for Sony the
leaks itself showed you the only Studio
that has been holding them on their back
this whole
generation certain things haven't been
profitable certain things haven't been
uh shown to be substantiated as far as
the words that's been spoken like this
stuff is making x amount of dollars this
is being sold this is this let me look
that's not
real the facts of the matter is those
leaks were of course the Wolverine being
leaked out that's not fun I didn't play
it I don't care about that stuff I don't
want to do that yeah hell with that um
and all and all of you nasty little
mutants that's out there sharing it out
and and and having fun playing it yeah
that's wild that's that's that's kind of
disgusting but they didn't want us
talking about what we found out it has
nothing to do with the de developers
information personal information even
though that Within itself if you have a
billion dollar company and you're not
invested in cyber security at this point
in time what's wrong with you especially
if you have been hacked at least three
times this year and you didn't double
down to your listen developers check it
out we are investing heavily in this
area if you didn't feel that that was
something of a
priority then something's wrong with you
because how can a developer go to work
knowing that cyberwise they're going to
be okay they're going to be fine this is
this is postco this is not during the co
time where people had to send
information back and forth and a lot of
leaks came out so when it came out for
Microsoft it was all cool we found out
this information we found out that if if
this had been on Microsoft end you would
have hear nobody coming out saying well
what we want to do is be respectful and
not Shar this out no no no no no you
will not save Kong bro Kong will die and
I don't care how you try to spin it I
don't care how what what moves you try
to put on it we found out y
bro we found out that the games y'all
said B Money didn't we found out the
choke hoold that y'all in from Marvel
for until 2035 y'all are in a choke
hoold I've never even heard yo what type
of deepo crap is that like you yo y'all
did well lock them up for 30 to 2035 put
them in the Cho and yeah we want 250 mil
off the top so you're mean to tell me
the game has
to it costs 300 million to make said
game you owe 250 million so you need
550 million just to cover the problems
and after that that's when you start
making bread but then you got to pay
Distributors you got to pay
bro I don't see how that is Su that
sustainable I don't see how that part
it's the was talking about and and the
problem with it is y'all y' Y cheering
these games that yeah they're the home
of Marvel they do but at what
cost at what cost I don't think that
contract that slave contract that they
got there like a slave contract that
contract is town to UFC contracts for
Fighters these dudes making they're
doing the best could you imagine Conor
McGregor doing so well in the UFC and
his biggest payday is when he had to
step out and fight
Floyd so it's not sustainable this is
the reason why UFC fighters leave and go
other places this is the reason why
ungano is boxing now this is the reason
why that happens they're going to force
you out of the
business they got to renegotiate that
contract and I don't think Disney Marvel
will ever renegotiate cont got are like
the biggest characters like like over
X-Men could do it but they couldn't do
it with any other characters yeah like
they they they needed the biggest in
order to charge the most yeah yeah for
sure I mean do you think do you not
think that obviously it was leaked that
uh you know they're going to I don't
don't know if we should say the
characters but they are going to be
working with other characters in the MC
universe
off of those characters in general do
you think that they can get similar
success that they got with Spider-Man no
oh no I I don't listen I'mma be real
with you after what happened with
Spider-Man
2 you're gonna have the qu ey for wol
ring how woke is this thing gonna
be what's going on over
here what are we going to have x23 here
too as well is she going to replace
Wolverine before the game is over
M what what's going to really happen is
saber to going to be uh changed into a
female like what's what's going to
really happen here well how woke is this
game going to
be the problem is Marvel lost their
credibility they passed that on to Sony
Sony had to put that woke nonsense
inside Spider-Man too oh so your your
concern not to cut you but I just want
to be clear your concern is because
right now there is a contingent that are
not happy with the MCU movies B what
you're saying right so you're you're
saying that maybe the Marvel shine is
not at his Heights right now and they're
locked into a contract with something
that could be locked into the
Titanic Marvel's best days is is is
pretty much behind them until they can
get it together they haven't shown that
they able to get it together okay the
last movie the Marvels was the absolute
worst thing that they ever put out so do
they have that luster yo Sony brought in
when Marvel was at their highest m
so you paid the premium dollar you've
been locked in at a rate that's not good
for you you need to renegotiate that
rate you need to renegotiate at the rate
of the Marvels not
at yes is ridiculous come on King
no G said don't tell me X-Man is going
to be called X people now yo but they
but they said that they you're laughing
they said that they're talking about
that in the comic books
but and he this is the reason why he
said listen they negotiated at endgame
right when they was at their peak of
course it makes sense then but now you
see Marvels you need to negotiate at
Marvel's bro you need your contracts
really need to be 120
million maybe less maybe 90 million off
of the payback off for licenses because
I don't think Sony is getting they need
to make money and they're playing in
read too much and it's going to be one
of these games that's going to sink them
and and you also heard that if they
don't make the game that they're
scheduled to make they still got to pay
up what type of Puff Daddy crap is this
like this is a some take that take that
not the Diddy like if you don't pay up
you still oh if you don't put the
product out I don't care about you be
have my
money it it doesn't work out well for
Sony Ratchet and Clank didn't sell and
went to no money and they put it on PC
still made no money the PC numbers look
horrible
abysmal they got to go date and date all
that stuff was there this is what they
didn't want us to hear this is what they
didn't want us to talk about they they
don't care they not that they don't care
about the developers information being
leaked that's unfortunate yeah but not
one time did we hear about that part
what we did hear about is
ratchet and Clay not making no money
Marvel got them in the choke hole Sony
in the red they need some help and uh
Wolverine got leaked that's what they
didn't want to talk about and and for
you to have a platform and you in the
game as a shirtless Spider-Man
bro broh really you supposed to be like
I can't talk about this I'm in the game
I'm I'm not GNA talk about this but um
what I would say is please don't share
it out and just walk away but you made
yourself you want wanted to go down you
wanted to be a pariah and you wanted to
bring all this upon yourself and you
have but I'm going to talk about it
always but I ain't gonna talk about the
the leaks of the people's information
because I don't care about that but what
I do care about is Kong ain't gonna make
it out of this generation Kong is going
to die and you can't save Kong so this
is what we on we on PlayStation 6 is not
showing up and y'all gonna be an app
that's what you want fair enough kiss Mo
what's going on the best how we doing
sir what's up can you guys hear me yeah
yes sir look he he took our mics yeah
got the mic situation going on I see you
yeah I had to I had to man I like you
guys are like know flating in I was like
I got I gotta get I gotta get on my ILP
like I respect you know what it was me
and him playing on Xbox and the voice
the differ
playbox they said it was levels with
they okay okay yeah yeah no doubt no
doubt so smooth man um how we feeling
like obviously you know we were away a
lot of this stuff went down as far as
inom leak so yeah smooth ain't really
talked about it publicly either weapon
wheel has been gone too yeah that's
right you guys been going too so the
question I have for you is um in
reference to obviously the ethical
portion where some people were like hey
don't cover it you know and the
obviously the second portion is what
probably surprised you most about the
leaks
itself uh wow um well I think the most
surprising about the leaks is just
amount of D data uh
that the data that was uh coming out of
these leagues is in regards to like
Wolverine uh the game play um them
extracting and making it playable um I
do
think the
reporting of the the leaks and the
punishing of the reporting of the leaks
I think is a bit overboard because I
think it's um you know a bit unfair uh
to be critical of people Spreading the
News because if this was any other you
know publisher or you know developer
everybody would be on it for the clicks
it's the hottest thing um out there uh
so the ad Revenue would be up for
everyone and I think uh I I don't know
why you know certain Talking Heads uh
take a certain point and and be you know
high and mighty on you know what we
should report on what we should talk
about what we should share um and and
it's all a part of the it's it's all a
part of the the game you know what I
mean things leaks we you know some of
our best work come from like leaks and
and rumors and unfortunately you know I
hate you know that you know Insomniac
some of the you know personal data
happens you know there's human beings
who get docs all the time and don't get
the same level of care um so you know I
do feel for them on that you know what I
mean and you know they're hard work you
know being put out like that but at we
got to be consistent if we're going to
have that attitude then you know let's
not report on on leaks period let's not
spoil things remember you know Jeff key
didn't mind spoiling the price of the
Xbox One X back in 2017 an hour before
they uh showed off the console um like
this stuff happens all the time it's
just the energy is different depending
on who who it is and I think um the
industry journalists you know content
creators we got to be consistent you
know what's what's right what's wrong
and what are we going to report um but
don't take time and like all right you
know you're not allowed to do this and
you know what I mean it just it just
looks like very Brown nosy
but fair enough fair enough I hear where
you're coming from um now reference to
the leaks themselves out of all tons of
data obious like what is it like a
terabyte full of data that that was
leaked you know out of the information
cuz what you said I agree with kiss
which is like you know all these leaks
we've all covered before in general
right but like nothing of this scare
where you learn so much information
about a studio and even from the
mothership from Sony and so so out of
the leaks if you can like what was the
stuff that was the most surprising to
you or made you go wow okay I I don't
know if it's surprising but I was
shocked to learn it this way and that
was the they acquired the X-Men yeah
yeah I mean it's was like oh okay well
there's uh
another Xbox ain't getting and not until
I'm at least
50 that's a fact that's a fact it's like
so those documents were very revealing
and then how much they have to sell to
maintain the U exclusivity and whatnot
so it's that I think that was more so
the biggest shocker it's like okay we
know you know Wolverine was a little bit
you know further out we know I think
they leaked that a Venom game was coming
and we kind of got a tease of that with
the with playing the Spider-Man game but
knowing that they secured uh an X-Men
game I think was it the deal was for
three games I believe I believe so yeah
and the the the the numbers behind it
and what also people I don't know if
everybody peeped this the
cost I'm like these budgets bro these
budgets take that take
that Insomniac ain't gonna be making or
rash in clanks anytime soon but um I
think that was more so the biggest
surprise that for me uh to see that like
I'm I'm not really surprised that they
secured it it's just that oh we got the
whole pipeline I mean a lot of these are
like play if there's a PlayStation 6
these might be PlayStation 5 Pro
exclusive according to King
D no fair enough fair enough no I with
you man those are definitely surprising
um I'll jump in you know the ethical
part you know sof was cooking earlier
before he left and I'm in this pretty
much the same exact pocket as him you
know look y'all know I'm prodev y'all
know I hate what happened as far as from
an ethical standpoint to insomnia no
Studio deserves that nobody deserves
they bsiness especially the personal
information that's just foul right you
know what I'm saying and anyone covering
that is is foul so you know I'm not I'm
not going to be a fan of that and I'm a
person who actually been a victim and
King knows like I've been a victim of a
vicious data breach in my life you know
where it really affected my life the
family a lot of things so I know what
that feeling is but you know that now
that being said like you know like we
said earlier we've always covered data
breaches you know what I'm saying
whether from journalist you call
yourself a or content creator things of
that nature and it's just like we're not
going to play double standard now and
and just because look we love insomnia
and not just because it's a or it's a
Sony studio you know what I'm saying we
cannot pick and choose what we're going
to talk about because at the end of the
day the the rationale is there's so much
information that you can actually learn
on how the business Works actually works
and this coming from themselves so to me
this is no different than the Capcom
leagues it's no different than when
Microsoft saw full nextg road map now
again people say yeah they leaked that
themselves but people were still
disseminating the information people
were still talking about people had time
stamps leaking each leak what we're
going to do how we going to talk about
it and things of that nature so you know
where the thing to me came to head and
adct can really relate to this cuz me
and him really were involved is that the
things we were seeing is look we've seen
a lot of we're pro developers we got a
lot of friends that are developers
behind the scenes right and we seeing
people outside with it King like if we
you know and we seeing PR people outside
like if we catch you talking about it if
we catch you this that and the third you
know oh you're dead to us and you know
me personally yeah I took offense to
that because it's like oh okay so now
we're being threatened you know what I'm
saying that if you even the mere mention
of it just because it's Insomniac or
Sony studio we're not doing that but In
fairness because I don't want to go and
make it a public disrespectful thing and
we going back and fourth what me and
adct did is we talked to some developer
friends behind the scenes and we just
said okay so help us understand your
position and part of it we get it that's
like your colleague you're like yo that
happened in somniac man that could
happen to us right so we get especially
if you work at
Sony so we get that part right we get
that part and the the the the example
they say well K you know you know a lot
of this is signal boosting you know what
I'm saying because a lot of people don't
read the titles a lot of people you know
the thumbnails stuff like that so what
the middle ground we came to is this
like cuz number one is like yo we're
going to cover this you know what saying
that's that's not going to we're going
to do our job as what we've always been
doing as content creators but what I do
understand is okay if you like right now
we doing a show and I got Wolverine
Alpha footage going on in the back you
know what I'm saying then that's fa if
you got someone's personal information
running around then that's foul now if
you super descriptive in your titles or
whatever whatever I get it as far as
sbles because we do know some people
just read the titles of something or
they just see a thumbnail or something
and that's it so that was kind of the
middle ground and stuff like that and
and cooler heads prevail and thankfully
you know people understood it I shout
out to Dinger from Arcane cuz he had
like a really good tweet kind of break
it down both sides of how everybody feel
now to leak themselves um
man sha lanon was was on something you
know about these these gaming budgets
they're insane these licensing fees that
market Marvel is it is is insane and
then what I thought was interesting is
like what was needed even Sony showing
their concern what was needed just for
them to break even you know what I'm
saying with these budgets over yeah it's
it's really to the point where they're
even concerned need a
kidney see were they even concerned
about you know potentially raising game
prices up to $80 no that's 150
bro that wasn't you
wasn't that's on Xbox front line go
check them out no no no they just say
they was going to break that spider up
the three I see I see two I see two for
the
50 follow K Xbox One live
man give you to your H BR baby pause y
you killing me so like I was saying they
were talking about it's funny when
people are asking King for sources I'm
like like just tell him it's Kan a news
oh he oh he'll let you know that it's
G yo I go around I clip everybody's
stuff I read everybody stuff and you
don't believe me believe K that
news here the thing when it comes to let
me let me get my finish my BS I finish
my sorry so um yeah now what I was going
to say is that like again that was an
option being discussed on the table to
split up Spider-Man 3 into separate
titles the thing to me and I got I'mma
Be A little slightly messy but I got to
be real is
that the the we all know Sony 3 to one
right three to one as far as console
sales and stuff like that what they
doing the generation and this is what's
been told of you know dominant and
that's what's supposed that's what's
matters you know the reality
is behind no court case no information
that where they feigning strength we got
the raw words from Sony about how they
really feel in reference to Game Pass
and the threat and we got the slides and
the slides picked a whole different
picture than what people are talking
about in ref prin the console sale so
here's here's the three things that they
said I'm just this is Sony's words he's
going to use this this is the sources
yeah this is Sony's words got the Call
of Duty threat Microsoft's AC
acquisition of Activision Blizzard could
disrupt and threaten console gaming and
game subscription markets they said they
were concerned about the shift from
PlayStation Xbox with the timing and the
game differential As Weapons
subscriptions as far as the exclusivity
creating greater dominance they talked
about how the impact packed to um
PlayStation plus they talked about the
threat of day and date of Microsoft
putting those games in there here's the
key word leap frog Leap
Frog gas you're a fool shout out to gas
setic sa in the building so they leap
frud this is the leader the console
leader telling you your Activision
provides um incredible strategic value
across live service games scale and
mobile and PC th front Microsoft can
supply multi-game subcription 50%
console games 50% and PC 60% they say
their own pillars are already dated and
behind the competition Sony is saying
that this is this is not this is what we
weren't no one's supposed to see this is
how they truly feel so that's why I I I
I I really tell people all the time this
is like hearing them when they talk to
their therapist be this is like you got
their words when they laying on the
couch with their feet up and their head
back and and they said well tell us how
you feel about Microsoft's Game Pass and
then and they they look over and they
say they going to Leap Frog I yeah Leap
Frog leap leap frog was the word that
was used and they say I like that I'mma
put out a shirt called Leap
Frog it's gonna be Game Pass Lea frog in
yo graphic God hey hey hey you know what
it should be it should be it should be
Godzilla Le [__]
over we on it we
but we got to talk about it because at
the end of the day we all been told Game
Pass is unsustainable we've all
everyone's been telling us that this
model that Microsoft's doing it's so
questionable and console sales that's
the tradition that's the way to do it
the first place market leader is now
mimicking the third place and saying
that their pillars are outdated so what
are they do really first place Co I
mean Lord we're not doing that but what
but whatever we're doing is we have to
be clear about how Sony views Game Pass
and how they are changing their
structure to mimic Xboxes that is the
fact this is from their own mouth this
is no one lying in court there no one
under duress this is how they feel so
this was their private thoughts yes this
is also they was pillow talking yeah
yeah they was laying down with Shorty
and shorty leaked them leak the
information out I like this so that
that's the thing I just wanted to
clarify because again again their own
words industry stft the leap frog active
visil in provides incredible strategy
against these lots of value across Lot
Service game scaling mobile PC front and
the last thing that I keep telling
people because everybody's like oh you
know the the the Call of Duty aspect we
get it but people keep forgetting about
the mobile front and the fact that
Microsoft is looking to do their own
store right and again a lot of Gamers we
don't like to talk about mobile we don't
care Stam over with the hardcore I get
it but a lot of that's going to
subsidize cost for the stuff that we
want and actually improve you know what
I'm saying their ecosystem as a whole
and that's what Sony said they said in
addition Microsoft is building a mobile
gaming store to compete with Apple and
Google these are things they consider to
compete with Apple and Google they don't
they not competing with Sony
right they
sundas don't don't don't do that don't
get me a CH
yo y'all don't y'all really don't know
who y'all are like y really acting like
y' got big wallets y' sua go get me a
Cho cheese shorty yo shorty you the one
with the purple hat get out of here and
go get me a chopped cheese that's what
you guys are and in your defense King
what it shows you are not enough the
console sales are not enough it does
show that that I got to give you your
your flowers so when Jim said that and
then he said that when he was selling
stocks yeah he said he said you are not
enough um let me get two on 10 um yeah
if you're calling your own model
outdated and you're about to be le Leap
Frog then you're looking to make changes
you know what I'm saying that's that's
just a fact we can't sugarcoat we can't
dance around it what can they do Co well
they got to they got to adapt that's
that's what they have to do what would
you do me personally I mean the thing
they already discussing it like I mean
what I would do if I was them or just
what think would you do if you was them
um the main thing is the m this is what
concerned me when you looked at the
steam sales and they had a slide what
really bothered me for whatever reason G
I'll let you jump in because I've been
talking for a while um is
that I was shocked that Miles Morales
didn't do as B like like I think days
gone and like they showed those those
did really well L Steve so I don't know
if that was more of the the newness the
fact that the games finally were coming
to PC but for whatever reason I felt
those numbers was soft for Miles Morales
on on PC so to me what it shows me is
maybe you know a lot of people don't
want to hear about the day and date
aspect but maybe they're leaving so much
money on the table by that year Gap they
mean they need to shorten that Gap or go
dur day but I don't think they want to
go D and date based on some of the
comments that I read in and stuff or or
maybe it's same ISM as far as what maybe
is it the game is exactly the same as
the Spider-Man and they were just like
you know PC guys are a little bit more
astute and they want different uh
different challenges and stuff like that
so maybe you know days gone it's
completely different than uh like let's
say if days gone 2 came out right and it
was the same exact thing with just a
different skin right I don't think it
would sell as much I think it would have
to do something different Miles Morales
we can all keep it a buck didn't do
anything really different right you know
it just gave you uh a a Hispanic black
player with a little different moves and
a nice story us as comic book heads we
love that stuff but does it Panda to the
PC crowd I don't think so I don't know I
mean it is interesting to see but I got
more stuff to say but I've been rambling
for while and I know um addict and I got
we I'm just like to be messy that's all
that is we got little G who's been in
realing a minutes G the septic sauce
have't see you how you doing sir I seen
him that's my guy I haven't talk to G in
a minute so I'm excited like I'm started
to think why yeah that's why that's why
I told I said please we out the gas see
get a man I want this
it's all it's all love you already know
so like how you feeling just the two
things first cuz we haven't talked about
this in a while you you guys you you
know have been talking about it and this
is kind of our first time back so the
ethical aspect about the leaks
themselves you know some people have
made decision we're not talking about it
that type of thing and then the second
about what was the most surprising what
did you extrapolate the most from the
data of the leagues FL yeah so so the
ethical aspect I I have to quote my my
boy ACA here where he says you don't get
to pick and choose when you start
to become ethical you've had a very very
long uh Legacy of reporting on it and
all of a sudden we're supposed to adopt
this attitude why like we've had very
similar with Capcom we had personal
details leaked it was a malicious hack
and all the like loads of stuff happened
and then you had you know the likes of
Greg Miller and stuff like jokingly
laughing at the fact that there will be
punitive measures taken against them as
they've got the leaked footage there on
the screen so I'm like come on bro you
think we care like you reporting on this
no I'm look I genuinely so you mentioned
that it happened to you so you
understand how disruptive renders that
can be and it is and as a creative
person you just have to just have some
empathy and take for as a second or
moment to think about the people who are
working on it like if I had a video that
I've been working on I've been working
on the relaunch of my chall for channel
for a while if some of my stuff like
even though it's not even remotely
comparable in terms of the time spend
the investment hard work of all the
people involved I would be devastated if
my work got revealed that way absolutely
so when I say the human element of it I
don't virtue signal like some people on
social media uh I I feel it because I
take my time to think about it I think
that's bad but look that's the state of
play no you you it's
like
[Laughter]
what ridiculous that's not it is you
can't you can't deny it like it's going
to happen someone's going to report on
it it's happened it's out there in the
wild builds are there people are playing
on PC like what's happening we've done
it for ages if my stuff goes out there
it goes out there whatever reason I as
much as I dislike it so that's the
ethics of I think the the you know I
I've been quite vocal even though people
misinterpret what what I say I say I
believe in the Xbox taxs generally
because of Microsoft's performance and
the media's Affinity with PlayStation
and you know not trying to get burned
with them there's good and bad there but
at the moment that I was saying that I
was like just calm it down let's not
play the victim here this happened and
then I watched the the media have this
circus with the ethics and this complete
absolute hypocrisy because that's use
the word it is hypocrisy so I look at
that I'm like right now I'm like I just
told people to down with the
Xbox you just literally throw that in my
face you screw it go go I can't defend
that it's stupido um so there's that
element of it but the the timing of it
God you work in my serious and beautiful
way well everyone is talking about Xbox
go third party this and that we get this
absolute absolute shotgun to the face
reality check cuz like you said this was
pillow talk this wasn't this wasn't this
wasn't them dressing it up for the FDC
there was no court thing you know like
how all the discourse was there they're
really exaggerating Phil Spencer was
exaggerating everybody's fed St like
everyone this was stuff we were not
supposed to see and I think and I think
Microsoft like I genuinely think if
Microsoft like obviously Microsoft are
licking their lips watching this yo
what's going on
here ridiculous yeah they're just
watching that um I think they would have
been like yo hold on a minute these guys
are playing it closer to the wire than
even we thought because and let me let
me say something since you said that I
think that's maybe when they said you
know what we was going to go in 2028 cuz
we thought they were stronger that's the
next one we'll get that they weak as
hell yo f up in their mouth right now
man I'm just saying no no but it's yeah
well I don't think they were ever going
to go out in 2027 but what I was going
to say is that if I was Microsoft that
really reinforced confidence in our
model because not only shows that Sony's
desperate for a pivot the the internal
thing shows that how delicate their um
model is despite the enormous success
with the hardware absolutely killing it
yes the problem is the profit margins
aren't high enough two they're pivoting
for a reason three Jim Ryan expressly
with his own mouth says consoles aren't
enough so you see it in their actions
you see it in the words you see it in
the absolute explicit discourse leaked
content which people tried to deny it
wasn't even oh try to say it wasn't real
I saw that yeah I did see it everyone
was convinced oh this ISS and then boom
there it is everyone's downloading it
from the same files and like there it is
as part of the discourse then then you
you know I disagree with King on the
know ps6 thing but then when I look at
this I'm like but you also thought
Ratchet and Clank was profitable too
right I'm just saying like like listen
everything see y'all until somebody else
tells you y not going to believe it and
and this elates my point my point right
here until somebody show something and
tell you we got to wait for somebody
else to tell
us I will build a statue get your chisel
ready there's no ps6 get chisel
ready get it ready I told y'all dudes I
said I don't believe these guys like
every time they sit there and T Numbers
you got to believe me bro I've been
around fake [__] M
PA this my first day back I apologize
I've been I've been around them my whole
life so and C knows this C knows like I
can sit there with him and I be like dud
to be popping something and I be like Co
that ain't real just did a B on us I
said I said I said c that ain't real and
K be like but B I'm like I'm telling you
it ain't real and then we find out ain't
real so these dudes have been talking
this forever and then when the paperwork
comes out I'm like see what I said not
real and then further exacerbate the
point contract they end with Marvel is a
absolute choke hold it's a absolute
choke hold breath and you notice hit it
with the breath you notice so if they
got this this lasso around their neck
and they got they got to make up these
numbers and Marvel and Disney is killing
their self on this end cuz their movies
aren't successful now dudes aren't going
to the movie theater for it how does
this help you before they was a boost
now it BEC an arbitros right so so you
sit there and say yo it's gonna be lit
Wolverine is gonna be lit what if Marvel
do something stupid from here to then
and they Wolverine is whack whatever
they do with wol cuz you know say the
x23 she going to be the character right
and and and they do that in the movie
let's say that Deadpool movie comes out
and they they it Wolverine in there is
horrible what does that do to your game
I mean yeah the same applies to Blade as
well and I think that's blade is so far
out we don't care yeah true all right so
then you know Blake can flop as much as
he want to flop it ain't that ain't
gonna stop the bread the bread is right
over here well that's the thing the
bread that they use and rely on is
starting to get stale because and it's
getting expensive to produce so
Insomniac is completely resigned to
being a Marvel studio and a lot of
honest PlayStation fans a few not a lot
I don't want to exaggerate this a few
handful do PlayStation fans said it's
sad that insomnia relegated to just
making comic book movies which is a
microcosm of the the cinema industry and
the lack of creativity in that space so
I'm like I'm I'm yeah I'm an Xbox guy
and I laugh when PlayStation gets merked
but you know I did enjoy the PlayStation
when it was weird when it was fun when
it was taking risks and the problem is
this heavy Reliance on AAA big budget IP
which is not sustainable which is
absolutely not there is coming a point
where this Sony are and and and and I
get people oh guys you're I've said this
before that Sony are barreling towards a
very and they know it and they know it
they're very barreling towards an
unsustainable model and they're
desperate to do this gas element that
they've forsaken for an entire gen
because it fed them so one the PS4 era
whereas Xbox is very very uh well
acquainted with it because that's the
bread and butter of Xbox so I'm not
saying the PlayStation is doomed uh
Playstation and Sony their business
Sony's business reli on PlayStation the
PlayStation screws screws over then the
whole business tanks just that they have
to really pivot and pivot hard what does
that mean it basically means the main
thing that a lot of PlayStation Fanboys
heralded as the golden formula that
PlayStation is gone because the gas
pivoting you said you don't like gas you
don't even like multiplayer half of you
pretended that not factions being
canceled was a good thing and despite
spending years so basically got an
incomplete game with the last of us two
because it was excused because it was
multiplayer was coming later so let's
not talk about that but multiplayer like
you see people like BG and Jack well BG
mostly he's just crying about for BG on
that multi imagine being BG like I get
it from the in the neck from XBox guys
for some of the things I complain about
but that guy has a massive freaking
battle against it because PlayStation
guys pretend let's use that word clearly
pretend that multiplayer doesn't matter
so they put themselves in a corner the
core Gamers want their single player
games and that comes at M massive cost
that's not really paying dividend so
it's going to be very interesting to see
all this in Industries in a state of
flux generally across the board AAA
that's going to be reworked across the
board and Xbox is more future proof
their business model is way more future
proof than PlayStations well said
brother no cooking not much more to add
to it the only thing I wanted to say was
just that um no addict's back I know he
want to get us a couple balls off before
I give it back to him was just that also
we forgot about the uh the sad reality
of we're just reading that despite the
success of of Insomniac how they have
layoffs him in it you know and the force
in that in in in a year that's the
craziest part of the whole thing yeah go
that I'll let you cuz I know you
supposed to go before just finish what
you're saying then I'll no that's pretty
much it I just like how how you know to
to to see if you're a member of that
studio to learn that it's kind of
beneficial in a way that you learn
through a leak that yo you know they
have to reduce Workforce they have to in
order for in order for them to be
sustained this is one of their most
successful Studios we can make the
argument that Insomniac has kept Sony on
their back through the entire PS5
generation if where would they be
without Insomniac right
bushes you are ridiculous I haven't seen
the bushes in a minute but um yeah you
know that that part was really
surprising to me and I know a lot of
devs felt that when they when they saw
that part but ad I'll let you finish up
your topic then we move on I
think I think my biggest issue with this
whole matter is I I do feel like the
industry itself
would love this and what I mean by that
is you know we we we've been covering
this industry for a long time we have
but at the same time PlayStation to
die no no no that's me that's just me
over that's king that's King's
thoughts here bro just me just just me
go ahead no I think the industry would
love the ability
to just like oh you talk about the Le we
going to get you up out of
here and that that was my fear it's like
you know because I don't particularly
believe Greg 100% meant what he was
saying uh you know I do think he he felt
that way towards Insomniac but is it
because of the situation going on
because of the relationships he have and
where does one end and one
begin and and to me you'll go out there
you know you you'll try to to get this
real positive movement going that you
consider it but then let's say it would
have worked because Greg got a lot of
backlash like a lot imagine if he didn't
get the backlash imagine if everyone
came together and said you know what we
shouldn't be covering
leaks then I feel like yeah but but but
then I feel like the pr the industry uh
all the console manufacturers all the
Publishers will come together because
it's not the standard to Blacklist
people for stuff for covering leaks yeah
but I feel like you really itching that
line trying to make a movement like that
because then guess what would
happen I guarantee you PR people in the
industry can't stand when we talk about
leaks they would love if every time
something leaked no one talked about it
but the problem is is what could they
realistically do they can't they can't
just go out here and say no one can talk
about it we're a Black List they can't
do that it's not good they're not able
to do that I will make a bot Channel and
go
crazy but you're
ridiculous if if someone as big as kind
of funny started moving on that started
moving on that that movement you know
and then before you know I think gam
spot jumped on it thank God you know I
Kaku IGN I jump on covered it I clown
IGN
247 seven days a week it's always smoke
with IGN with me but get gang stuck once
it's up it's stuck with at it you heard
it's clearly up this is this is one of
the scenarios where IGN did the right
thing oh you know wow see but I have no
problem giving them props when props is
deser there's not a whole lot of
opportunities in in in my whole time
covering where there prop your weapons
down I appreciate you but this is the
one time where put the guns down he put
the guns down okay Dustin uh you know
Ryan okay cross the street I'm my man I
appreciate you we put no violence non
violent 10 minutes later I need you to
go back over we
ouru self
destruction it just comes down to me
it's just
like I I would hate I would have hated
for no one to said nothing and you know
cuz there's a lot of people uh that
agree with Greg and you know no one
wanted uh you know someone like
Insomniac and then before you know it
we're starting to get hit with uh you
know no email
responses and and then before you know
it GRE just trying to protect a
relationship he done stopped him from
covering every other leak in the
industry y thankfully that that was that
was my fear thankfully that didn't
happen because the industry revolted
back and and I I'm pretty sure it would
have cuz that that's something I mean
gas how often do we talk about leaks all
the time yeah if we can't talk about
leaks we might as well shut all our
stuff down
today and the reality never going to
happen yeah the informative things that
you learn about the game Cent right you
know how things really work I was going
to say something really
stupid I just say you can't stop us son
it is what it is let's move let's move
cuz we got a lot to get into but you
want to help out on on the chest before
we move into the next one yeah web dayve
what up doc do what up fun speculation
what up I see a lot of y'all up in here
black Vie DK griggy what's going on bro
the dirty one my
God going on thank you thank you for
holding it down while I was sick keeping
the boot on these ponies necks I love it
keep going
all me what's going on we were you guys
have been very super chat's been crazy
yeah post up what up okay so we got $5
Super Chat from suu Sage I feel bad for
everybody sleeping on Xbox this year
Xbox has two megatons to drop this year
that nobody will see coming not a rumor
a promise we got a member uh CH uh CH
Walker been a member for 30 months
that's what's up Happy New Year Lords
it's not even been a week into into the
year and media start rumors to create
Xbox confer we going to get into it we
gonna get into it we got a 32 we got a
member chat from sujju Sage been member
for 32 months if they behaving like this
already when just Starfield dropped I
can only imagine how they'll behave when
elder Girl 6 drops and Xbox keeps adding
more exclusives and Game Pass day ones
we got that $ five Super Chat from JD
gamer pathetic P begging ponies got no
games and PS Pro can't save you you
can't save Kong we held the line then
Advanced the line and now it's reward
time your man is outside King you're yes
we keep it live that's right my real
rights keep it live baby let's go we got
a $2 from mmac
2254 we're just moving on adct can you
put a link to join them the channel I
did it's uh it's down there somewhere uh
bats the $10 Super Chat they can't save
call $2 for JD gamer they can't say King
yeah this just literally his soldiers
paying you to
read welcome uh iMac uh to the rail put
for in there so I guess he did find that
link I put in there we got a $5 Super
Chat from cetric H there's a lot of lot
lot of lot of
lot of smoke going after someone named
cetric today but anyway s signed a 360
deal with Marvel y they did they got
their L they got everything s a 360 deal
yo you Wilding with that yo you got kid
mooth laughing the that workk oh my
God he said a 360 from bats King is the
cat the K the cat of The Gaming
Community he's cat well he forgot what
by exposing these frauds out here trying
to save Kong # Advance was on sh juste
I told you he had a Tay I told you that
wasn't his ha but y'all wasn't listening
to me he don't write his own jokes be he
don't right his own J son continue we
got a $5 Super Chat for oh no we got two
two super chats from DOA Targaryen I
think yeah yeah yeah you got it that's
what's up $5 Super Chat uh you know next
time put some letters in there man $5
Super Chat from Rapture press Network
Marvel and Sony work together due to the
Spider-Man film rights Disney has to go
get Spider-Man for the MCU Sony needs
MCU for big payday Thor 4 is the worst
film okay he's saying Thor is the worst
film King not not Marvel that's nice go
watch the Marvels don't
talk Super Chat from JD gamer pathetic
Port bagging ponies got no games # ps6
going facts I told you man that man is
gang banging outside
with heavy 505 he's been a member for
over two years whoa just like that IOP
is back much love everyone salute $2
Super Chat from James Thomas it's going
to be marbles The Last of Us with Logan
and
x23 I have no clue yeah I know what they
doing I feel like I spoiled something I
don't know no you're good you're good
you're good to Super Chat from uh Miguel
I
Ivers uh you know it's uh King equals
facts Integrity give me a break Sony BTS
talking about fearing a in a Microsoft B
frog of uh off console success PSA lays
off Studio closure biased media ain't
touching that come on now facts that's
right you s the most Spider-Man games
ever and by the way y gotta lay off 70%
of your dude say what never cuz
King sell those those copies B Super
Chat also King where's free R Kelly he's
been Max quiet somebody go check on him
is he in witness protection laugh out
loud B $2 Super Chat from JD Gaber
pathetic P begging parties keep we
frogging man got a member CH from slowo
backs slaps he he's been a member for 42
months so here we go what should they do
they should cancel Destiny and have bung
do do the cancel factions too having a
hard time doing their own game much less
picking up someone else's slowo so mess2
super CH from Mr mdj uh King calling out
fake naysayers
today facts
Bo and don't believe me until they got
um hyper King hyper King X3 I got you
welcome Lord Lord gold JD gaming $2
Super Chat Kong is down yo punch him in
the mouth right
now Spartan 661 $2 Super Chat submission
hole say uncle Co
Sony bad mad Mo member salute # boot on
the next season happy New Year shout out
to the Lord to the pattle here's to
another great year with the Lord salute
then we got this black Viking Long Hong
long house gaming podcast follow super
chat if kind of funny aren't media
journalist how can they vote in the game
awards then you got a little eyeball
Emoji oh we got harit Chie remember for
months yes yes I remember Pony is's
talking about Starfield flopping
Starfield made his money back in
pre-orders spider Cube 2 is a flop
though worry about PlayStation yo he
messing that worry about PlayStation not
the trillion dollar Microsoft hashy New
Year hey King
King Xbox don't have to pay for all
these crazy loyalty uh deals when it
comes to to starfi like PlayStation do
no they don't that's straight up did you
see the loyalties on that stuff it was
crazy talk about the royalties yeah that
yo they make so much
bread and that just go straight to the
wallet yeah y'all dudes y'all got to pay
back before y'all pay up and then y'all
can't pay out y'all dudes man y'all the
dudes come Friday I got you come Friday
Hollywood rules5 Super Chat you can't
save Kong Happy New Year to my New York
City and West Virginia cousins caning
get well the port begging is at an
all-time high now we counting third
party games all got a $5 Super Chat from
country big 94 Happy New Year to
everyone in the realm this year going to
be a great one finished Allan Wake 2
over the holidays amazing game remedy
are top tier I'm going make sure that my
brother didn't just super chat that that
sounds like a username he would pick no
no you for real he UK in the building he
a wrestler no I was joking I was taking
Jabs up my brother okay you shooting
okay I got you I got you yeah uh we got
a member chat from from scrub nurse been
a member for 42 months Happy New Year
Lords love all the work and effort you
guys put into it and it shows hit that
like button and subscribe shout out and
hold the line blessings we we got a $10
Super Chat from gaming Forte posted a
video on Twitter earlier last year
stating Gamers on Playstation ain't
enough anymore that's why the whole
slate is coming all things change when
uh with time PlayStation won't be the
exception that's right
got a member chat from uh from flame
been a member for 38 months happy New
Year IOP I love that Xbox release the
series s toaster it's already more
useful to Gamers than the PlayStation
[Music]
P I gotta get my hands on one of those I
tried to get one of those on um what was
it Walmart website I got to get my hands
on them Cog since you over there and you
know out there you know in the land
where Walmart can exist you know I'm if
if you happen to you know drive past
yeah I can pick one up I got you and
then we got um we got a member chat hold
up uh we got um uh DEC uh
decado de okay you got he he gifted 10
he gifted 10 IOP memberships shout out
to him man he's gifted 30 memberships
this stream
wow we got a $10 super from col art
artistic uh Happy new no past uh
features weren't used much example PS3
uh cell chip of velocity Arch type now
with so many Xbox Studios it uh it lets
Xbox create console Tech that develops
that developers will finally take
advantage of yeah I believe in that got
a member track from Hollywood rules been
a member for 23 months uh Sony math
ain't math and they love consoles sales
numbers but don't want to speak on those
on the revenue numbers it's not about
the plastic it's about the content that
part got a super chat for $2 from flame
also Warframe has more players on Steam
in Destiny 2o oh that's cute yall
finally got it got ahead what about the
uh console let's see how that's doing oh
you're not in the top you can win that
fight all day flame I'm I'm done with
the he not in the top by the way
warframe's not in the top 20 on on Xbox
just W let let him know just so he he he
he's aware got a member trap from JD
gamer been a member for 45 months um G
to get these ponies out of here sto them
from Port begging they got no games how
ponies let PS go for uh go for a whole
year with only one first party exclusive
that's their game of the year too they
won y'all did it yall did it y did it
y'all made up a award show you won the
only game you put out shut
up continue got a a member chat from
gaming Forte he's been a member for 48
months here to another year with the
Lords keep the content coming gas stay
on the ground kid I need a new rap video
and as always hey King boooo I be
telling smooth he needs hey Forte I be
telling smooth he needs to jump more
into entertaining people than giving
people's in uh than giving uh opinions
cuz I feel like he makes people laugh
people care about his opinions but I'm
going to keep going um we got a member
chat from [__] J 29 months Happy New
Year to the Lords much uh much more
success to you this year Kong will die
are we good we C hell yeah Kong will die
all right cool look this the big one
another one that was going on when we
were away Xbox next rumors going on
potential 2026 uh shout out to
wccftech uh they think uh Next
Generation Xbox will be powered by Zen 5
CPU due to launch in 2026 and um says
that it may be released early in the
PlayStation 6 as Microsoft wants to set
the message for the next generation of
consoles and also red gaming Tech
revealed the timeline and said it may
have shifted since the uh documents
leaked by the FDC early in the year and
um yeah they said that as for why
Microsoft could be planning to release
this uh console uh before is because um
the C company wants to set the message
for the next generation of consoles like
it was successfully done in the 360
generation the hallare would be less
powerful than the competition but it
would only make it cheaper than the
PlayStation 6 and allow Microsoft to
release a more powerful Hardware
revision down the line so uh yeah this
is a big one lot of thoughts lot of uh
debate and reference to this I want to
start with uh I want start with the best
spot want start with the best spot right
quick cuz I'm curious how you feel he's
he's a he's a he's a power guy he's a I
feel he's a guy like
he likes the power of mid generation
refreshes and consoles and things of
that nature but uh what do you think
about this man um if this rumor is true
do you agree with the strategy not hold
Pat you know where you at with this um
personally like I don't have a problem
with it because I can see how it's um
done and then what a way to do it you
know what I mean obviously if the
PlayStation 5 Pro going to come out and
you know Ste some headlines and then
Xbox turns around and releases a new
console so they can do this and they can
do this at any time they want because me
and adct has been arguing as we argued
about this over our planet Xbox episode
where I said it doesn't matter when they
drop they can drop two years early and
be fine because there's not I don't see
a situation where a game that is
playable uh for the next console that
won't be playable for the series X right
so it's like their Xbox with their
consoles are more closer to the mobile
of how like every iPhone can come out
whatever and it's just like hard yeah I
feel like it's going to be the same
thing it's just that they're going to
they'll be able to front on the power
and and have developers you know take
advantage of it and they they'll be they
could the only real exclusive they could
really have are the ones that are will
be provided by third party that's eager
enough to take advantage of that you
know that Tech um that's only available
that's how they got ahead with the 360
like there was just games that were just
available for a whole year for the 360
from 2005 to 2006 even going into 2007
that just they didn't uh port to the PS3
or that got ported to the PS3 much later
and it gave them like a huge leap I
think they're going for that again it
will be less disruptive I don't think um
it will be like a tight close off where
it's like all right here's the next gen
and the series X and S dies off because
there's a lot of games we've seen the
last two years that ain't coming out
until 2026 so are those all nextg games
like like that's where I say like they
can technically get away with doing it
and it it won't be as like a a crazy
shift and it honestly even though it
would be a next Generation console it
would probably feel more like what the
series X did to the Xbox One X you know
how we got the series X and S and there
was really no exclusive it was just
games that ran and looked better with
the upgrades but there was no concrete
like next gen exclusive they were just
all Xbox One games right running at um
with upgraded uh resolutions and frame
rates and I think it will be the same
thing pretty much serve the purpose that
the PS5 Pro would serve just to a
greater degree and I'm just curious to
see what changes they make that the the
backward compatibility with how how will
will they somehow to use machine
learning to you know put raay tracing in
games that didn't have it before like
like like what would they I'm just
curious I think it's a good idea for
them to break away from this from to
timeline
yeah yeah they have to do that and um if
they the reason why it makes me feel
good that they're doing this because you
know everybody says you know Xbox ain't
making no more consoles um is that they
still care enough to try to give it like
some sort of effort where like you know
we we want to put a console out we want
to you know set the tone like we did in
the 360 days and the 360 was successful
by beating PS5 to the like I mean the
Xbox OG Xbox had a short lifespan four
years yeah and um and so I'm not
surprised I'm happy with it I'm I I'll
support it but I feel like what they're
doing they're doing something where I
don't think it will force anyone to move
on for the series X and the series s
sooner than they have to but they have a
more powerful option that's far greater
than a PS5 and the PS5 Pro but you know
just ahead a couple years ahead just to
give them that room to like kind of
dominate the market and and and allow
their platform to mature to mature all I
feel okay okay I surprised I didn't know
how you was going to feel about let's
get guys man let's get the sauce real
quick so I I got a chance to listen to
you guys a reference to your thoughts on
this you know this is a big talk point
between me and ran we were going at it
for a minute but um yeah just in general
like what should I shouldn't say going
at it we were discussing it we
were yeah we wer going at it we wer
going at it we going at something else I
but not this but so where you at man if
if the rumors are to be believed and 20
26 is it do do you agree is the right
approach or you kind of like you know
what y need to stay stay pet for a bit I
actually got a couple of people in the
know who actually told me before the
wccftech that this is happening but
they're saying 2026 2027 2027 is more
likely again
I but believe it or
not but I think it's a smart move um I
think it also really right now as an
Xbox fan I get I'm a bit annoyed after
watch my language I'm a bit
the fact that um it feels like Microsoft
had this blunder brush approach of let's
get invite everyone like
K like that's the only thing I don't
like about Phil I'm like no man the
console make it because that's the the
nucleus of of this business and this
brand um so you know one people are
already saying there's not going to be a
nextbox and this would be a massive
serving of crow uh for them two it the
thing is the next gen console will be a
tremendous marketing beat because
Microsoft needs that breathing space
PlayStation dominates the air Airwaves
massively with the masses with the mass
public right so look think about it Call
of Duty is a huge IP Microsoft is now
contractually bound not to uh leverage
the advantage on its current gen
consoles over the PS5 but now it has a
PL Xbox next nobody a saying that about
a new exactly they didn't say they can't
be held back by that the next Xbox could
will have uh if they release it a way
better you know on paper and hopefully
in practice way better a generational
leap in what Call of Duty performs like
and people will buy that the Masters
will be swayed by the definitive version
of codon consoles doing all kinds of
like bro it's crazy how the M the market
is changing I'm one of my boys he's big
in the drill drill game called fumes the
engineer he was he's a PlayStation guy
and he's got a 4090 PC playing with a
PlayStation controller he's and all his
boys are moved to PC because they want
the definitive edition of what just Cod
war zone they just want to play COD
that's all they're playing you release a
next gen Xbox get the name right for
God's sake please get the name right oh
man they're they screw up their name so
bad it's so important it's so important
get the name right get it uh get the all
the marketing push and this is going to
be a cross gen console by the like I it
will be cross start that that is the
case now with this gen we saw it for 3
years man both consoles it just kind of
straddled the cross gen things it's
going to be a cross gen console by by
its extension so is the ps6 if if it
comes out it's not a USB stick whatever
be careful around say that I'm trying to
be careful I'm trying to be careful but
you saw me seeed
up talking to say the words ps6 K on on
continue
pause that's crazy I I think that
everything is lining up because a lot of
big games this strategy is very risky as
well but Microsoft can weather the storm
but it's risky because obviously the
PlayStation 6 could have technology that
is that would Leap Frog potentially the
P the Xbox next but then Xbox by then
can then commit to another M genen
console but the the strategy is risky
but it works really well and aligns up
with their software launch that yes
console needs to be front loaded with
Incredible first party IPS and without
that it's not worth doing I think that's
where Elder Scrolls coming out on the
next box that would be mad I think
Perfect Dark is around about them blade
like this is like the 360 gen when we
got project got them racing perfect dark
zero to a lesser degree but still a
marketing be and you had all these
incredible games so this would be if
Microsoft wants if Phil Spencer says
never got a chance and never with the
last gen guys can I interrupt you right
quick I just want to throw something
that's going to sound very crazy it's G
to sound very crazy 20 years later right
well 2005 launch title exclusives for
360 Quake 4 perfect dark zero Call of
Duty 2 yo history repeat not history
repeat don't get me gassed up now kid
that's crazy that's glorious those are
glorious it would work m that strategy
would be incredible think about a front
loed thing you're getting it the game
pass in Japan as well you've got Mina
working overdrive trying to completely
disrupt the market all the chips fall in
the right place and someone earlier in
one of the super chats did say made made
a great point where they said look with
all these Studios and the breath of
Studios now under Microsoft's Banner you
will start to see that technology
becoming useful more because Xbox
Hardware is not doing what it needs to
supposed to tools or whatnot that kind
of stuff getting ahead of the
competition getting developers
climatized to your Hardware software and
your tools two years ahead of the
competition is a big big plus that her
Xbox in this generation when the
PlayStation 5 was using the same Dev
environment that it relied on the PS4
now play Xbox gets ahead two two years
potentially that's a or one year
potentially that's a big big amount of
time to really go hard on the marketing
and Microsoft needs to do that and not
do some third part
I got one question before I pass it guys
yeah what do we do with the Dual skew
approach though do we are we dual
skewing or we are we one skewing what we
doing do no do not do a dual skew this
the strategy does not make sense if
you're going to try and undercut and
offer a cheaper alternative that's the
series X or the series s and even
cheaper you've got cross gen why do you
need to do deal deal SK the whole point
about the strategy yeah that's done
that's done that's a r i I think that's
done as well I don't think that's GNA
happen again I don't think that's gonna
happen again the second sco is going to
be the midgen console that comes out
later no that's not true oh you don't
think so King damn no I'm no cuz I put
the video out way oh cuz you cuz you put
the video Xbox front line go
watch go um yeah now soon as he finish
I'll tell you what it is okay so that's
what I think I think do not do not even
think about releasing a weaker conent
the whole point a whole marketing
Bluster about is most powerful console
this is it this one and have all the
software you've got you want to play
these games you can play on the Xbox you
can play on Game Pass you can play on PC
can play everywhere but you want the
definitive console version of this it's
going to be this and I think that that
strategy makes sense with machine
learning and all the bells and whistles
got give them all AI That's right cool y
crazy
ai ai up the wazo the wazo the wazo AI
is the future man man this something
we've been talking about room is is
cooking Xbox in 2026 what we doing you
you Fest you where you at or you not
shout out to the 10,000 watching get
them likes up you know you wipe your
feet you hit that that Bell when you
come in you put the thumbs up play with
me please yes there you go hit that like
button yeah come almost 433 like what's
going on now thums up something stinks I
don't like it it gotta be it must be a
lot of PlayStation dudes up in here
trying to figure out what's happening
what what what are they going tell us
that we got to do this year what do we
got to follow what do we got to run from
got to run from them leaks boy so adct
man how you feeling Shades at 360 hour
or we gas should we should we just chill
out and and relax I actually think
they're gonna they're going to pull a a
a Wii U what's the Wii U oh
no wow can you let me finish this D can
you let me finish I want you to go for
direction is gone thank you can you let
me finish they're going to they ended
the Wii U early to start the next
Generation a shot on everyone else oh I
I think that's what they're doing here I
think this year and the majority of last
generation was about damage controlling
what the the state of the the brand was
at the beginning they're starting to get
all their ducks in a row and I feel like
the best way because we've always said
it you know every generation's a new
fresh start and we seen how just a year
benefited Xbox with the 360 MH so you
know and not to mention not only does
that give them an advantage in that
perspective where you know the the
PlayStation five Pros coming out next
year Well rumored come out next year so
if that's genuine and that's actually
happening do you do you think that
PlayStation jumps the gun and stops
supporting the PlayStation 5 Pro like a
year year and a half into devel uh into
this into the market like because it
puts them in a situation where it's like
do we let Xbox run wild for a year or
two with a with the the next generation
of consoles or do we cut the PlayStation
5 Pro
early and meet them in the Market at the
same time and and part of me is on this
I think that they
know they have games as long as the
games hit they'll be fine and and part
of me thinks like look you know we
starting to get these games together
we're starting to get out all of our
ducks in a row if we jump the generation
soon and and are able to get to the
market before the competition because
look look what happens like every time
these new consoles come out it's like
the fresh thing on the market imagine
being the only fresh thing on the market
have it to because at that point
switches two three years the new
switches two probably years uh well
almost three three years new like and
then you know people say well you know I
think they're going to cut ties quicker
sooner rather than later I do think
there's going to be a loss cross
generation gains but I think they're
going to lean more towards that generate
that next Generation only on that
platform like I think there's a chance
Blade the blade is only on the next
genes and you know you know me and
smooth disagree because smooth says well
some of these games have been announced
for Xbox like but we've seen in the past
where companies say oh we're dropping
last and to me if they do that and they
have the games and they come out let's
say perfect Dart outer Worlds
2 uh blade Elder Scroll six nextg
only I think it could really benefit
them I I really do like it it only works
if they have the games the games are
going to be critically acclaimed people
are going to like them you know people
could sit there and say well addict you
know they're not going to restart a you
know another new generation but it's
just like that's what that's what the
Nintendo did and it worked for them like
obviously there's a mobile market aspect
to that but when they when they they
realize early on we ain't doing nothing
with this Wii U so we're we're going to
buide our time support it as much as we
can and we're going to make our efforts
Next Generation and I don't think that's
happening now but I do think that
Microsoft is is better off cutting the
cord sooner rather than later because
not only like I said it puts PlayStation
in a weird situation I don't think
PlayStation letting them do that I think
PlayStation Cuts support sooner rather
than later I personally feel like that
because if if XBox had a year on the 360
and was able to gain so much ground
imagine if they had to give them
two and I just I don't see PlayStation
doing that if anything if there was some
leaks going on and the moment
PlayStation finds that out they're like
we need we need our next gen out sooner
rather than later and I'm sorry King
it's the ps6 like I I just I don't say
sorry to me just say sorry to
yourself you because you're wrong but I
mean I'm just G to sit here until you
right that that's that's my thing I'm
very intrigued on how this is going to
pan out and you know the funny thing is
like I said on I'll go live but there's
a ps6 king like
get at least at least you know me at
least you know me at least you know me
but it's not it's not yo it's it's just
not and and y'all are so used to
something that y'all will like to be
safe I don't care to be safe out gold
PL and I want you to make sure that the
Mallet look like a Thor hammer when
you're doing it you
saying head at the end of it don't worry
even if PlayStation
can't even if PlayStation isn't able to
come out in
2026 they can't they're definitely
coming out in 2027 like 2027 I
don't huh 2028 28 they ain't come out 27
I you guys really think they're going to
let Microsoft run two years in a
generation by themselves it's not what
they let them do is what they able to do
they can't why you saying 2028 in
general King the ps6 don't exist why you
saying 2028 in general listen I'm well
I'm telling you this if they're able to
make any moves is only in 2028 the y'all
don't read y don't read y' don't I sat
there and read every document I sat
there with bleeding eyeballs reading
everything and said and you know I just
felt like that I belled the mouse like I
got them like I've got them so when
dudes are sitting there talking this
crap like it's gonna be this I'm like
y'all just didn't read didn't and and
the fact of the matter that y'all didn't
read is my gain it's okay it's okay okay
you're ridiculous but as you as you it
goes on to you right now King
I didn't get a chance to talk to you
about this um on no front lines out
there we had this in-depth discussion in
reference to you know Xbox next 2026 do
they set it off early do you with this
you with this kind of ener first the
first the first paperwork showed that
they was talking about 2028 right yes
right and um then the leaks came out and
then all of a sudden these dudes is like
yeah now we can go 2026 well well Phil
did say Phil did say hey those old we
our players CH yeah yeah we changed we
changed cuz we found out a lot of new
stuff like when you find out the dude
that you you you you going ball for ball
line for line he ain't ready yet oh he a
get his Beats right yet oh wait a second
he he can't make it to deide with us
this oh let's go it's a go it's a go
when you find out that you going up
against bases like this is Tower let's
play Tower Defense right right and you
find out they don't got something on
they side that can stop tanks y massive
make tanks make a bunch of tanks and
send them like we got them real real
quick question King do you think if what
whatever Xbox's next console is do you
think they do what they did for the Xbox
One to the series s and X where it is a
kind of like a UI not really a UI
overhaul it's pretty much the same
interface do you think they keep that or
you think they change it up no no
everything is going to be be all brand
new spanking because thei I think it
would be a mistake if they didn't that's
nice the the AI is going to is going to
show you exactly what it's about um okay
so first first start no tanks you found
out they they they can't defend they
can't defend against the tanks they
can't defend so what you do you send a
whole bunch of Tanks over there you just
adct is the master at this what when he
played um when we was playing that Halo
of Wars yes he's the master at it oh
they don't got nothing that can defend
about Ariel send mad Ariel over there
and wipe him out no you know what I used
to do I used to send an anti over there
where I knew I would have tanks and I
would send planes over there to what to
get the people that I want to kill with
the tanks to follow the the the planes
to my tanks and do you see that he
learned he knows strategy but he's not
using the hair now this is what I'm
talking about right this is the part I'm
talking about this is what they said
that if you want somebody to not know
what your plans are write it down and
put it in the
book I read everything read all I and I
said oh
snap these dudes don't got money these
dudes have been fudging numbers these
dudes have been actually weak as hell
and I've been saying in it for years but
y'all waited for another dude to say it
for
y'all I said it ain't no PlayStation 6
cuz when they say the competition will
Leap Frog us
we don't have anything that can
compete y'all are not
enough these are words telling you we
can't do
this when the CEO was selling
stocks why would you sell now why would
you sell it later when it's more
valuable no you going sell now when you
know that it's worth the most now tell
me how we talking about Xbox and he's
hijacked there's no
PlayStation no no listen let's get to it
let's get to it go to it let to it let's
get to it let's get to it I'm telling
you why they coming out in 2026 I'm
telling you why they going to punch him
in the mouth they catch the bully with
his pants down hold up just sock him
right in the mouth drop him right there
saying they just Johnny caged him just
just catch him in the locker room while
he pulling his pants up B just drop him
cuz he ain't know that you was there he
didn't know you was gonna show
up now the two skew
thing it's going to be one console one
official console come out okay but they
will have a little man and little man is
going to change y'all saw that whole
diagram that they put up with the
controller yes those those modulated
controllers it's going to be Tech inside
that joint to cloudstream immediately oh
Cloud didn't they confirm they canceled
that whole program though they didn't it
was called Keystone or something like
that they said they got rid of it they
canceled the Keystone project The Joint
that was on his dresser I mean on shelf
in the back yeah completely different
same Tech completely different see the
problem with the Keystone was you needed
a
controller so you're going to sell it
and buy a
controller uh you understand who's gonna
walk around with this big ass controller
in their pocket trying to get it over H
we're gonna rework this let's rework
this this is why that thing didn't come
out let's rework
it if you put the tech into a
controller that automatically syncs up
to any t anywhere right any any phone
whatever at any point in time and you
turn that into a battlefield anywhere
you are for $150 $200 and it only
streams this is only a streaming device
this isn't something that oh this this
is the dedicated Hardware That's how
little man get wings we got little man
got wings now and little man is not
holding back this guy because he doesn't
have Tech in it that you have to skew
for right I'm just saying like a cloud
only device all we got to do is just
manufacture this little dude let this
little dude go out there and do the
Infantry work and just knock people out
go go little man go do what you were
made to do and go beat people up real
console comes out now they got the games
they got the games y'all want I saw your
Port begging earlier I saw your Port
begging earlier your Port begging so
hard y' got cult out there making videos
talking about yo this stuff might happen
and this stuff might happen y'all are so
hopeful that y'all can get and it's not
even for y'all it's not it's for the
dudes that lay down easy it's for it's
for Nintendo okay so I can tell y now
that's for Nintendo you other Port
beggers y'all not gonna get that you
gota wait but this console is gonna be
AI
run and it's gonna Leap Frog them just
like they said it would it's going to
leave them in the dust cuz they going to
put out that Pro next year or or this
year I think it's this year that that
Pro supposed to whatever please put out
the pro soon as you put out the pro
that's when your feet is stuck in the
ground that's when you going to beat the
brakes off you this is where youall bend
over to tie your shoelaces and we GNA
come kick you in the mouth and that's
when the new Xbox is going to come out
now the name is key I'm not going to lie
yeah g is all not the name the the name
is key don't come out here don't mess
that up just just don't mess that up all
right I don't think it's going to be a
serious console don't mess that up just
just xB I don't know man I don't know I
just please don't mess let me ask you
this though cuz you you're of the
mindset you're from the era of we drop
your album on the same day as their
album now no no no no wait out hold on
wait a second you always been to drop
drop my game on the same day as there G
you've always been on that type of time
I'm also of the the type of time to
catch a dude while he
lacking I'm I'm the dude that CCH you
coming out your baby mama house what's
up B what's up now oh oh oh no oh no
remember what you
said I'm that dude I'm that dude that
cat you when you thought it was nice you
understand okay okay I got you now I got
you so just when y'all thought it was
safe to come
outside I'm that guy and I I want to C I
want them to catch them at they weakest
they weakest is when they trying to get
that Pro out when they got that Pro out
and your legs is stuck in the ground and
you trying to get your games over there
you trying we just trying to worry about
a generation that y'all quote unquote
said yall
won so I want y'all at your weakest
where y'all can't make the pivot y'all
already manufacturing this you can't
manufacture nothing else so they locked
in your feet is stuck to the ground s he
got him now you just come behind them
and bang
up put him down and put him down and you
can't be making that
sound you be making that sound that's
the new Xbox sound I don't like that yo
my my real rights know what happens yeah
I want I want I want them to get out
that car in that dark alley and just be
like it'll be really messed up if
somebody
ah right now so it's gonna happen
they're gonna catch him lacking because
the huus on these dudes is ridiculous I
don't even know why they would make a
pro but this is what they're going to do
and this is what Microsoft is going to
do and they know it it's predictive they
probably got an AI predicting everything
that they going to do over there and and
and strategizing against it but that
little man is gonna show up but it's not
going to be what everybody thinks it's
just going to be a streaming device that
can go anywhere latch on to anything at
any time to get that pockets that's it
all right y got most of the points I was
going to say um look at the begin it I
was mixed only because there's a part of
me it's like man y'all got the games now
y got the St
do you need to necessarily you know JP
out the window so to speak but there's a
part of me that I was like you know what
we got to be real like 360 was their
most successful generation you know what
was some of the the differentiators the
differentiators was yeah they were about
a year or two to market right when we
had Peter on and Peter talked about that
you know establishing that and being the
first to 10 million whatever the number
was at the time and um you know the
thing that really is compelling about it
is that
we have to be honest with the series
consoles one of the major flaws we all
had saw that series X that had Halo
infinite on the bag of the Box yeah and
Halo infinite was not ready for launch
that jint was there right so we remember
how weak the lineup was and as the
problem with the series generation is in
my opinion they haven't been able to
capitalize and gain the ground they were
because I don't as as dominant as Sony
has been with the 3 to one I feel
there's been opportunities for for Xbox
to exploit and they've had like a good
year bad year Good Year bad year so they
haven't been able to string it together
right so to me you jump out let's say
2026 or G say 2027 right you jump out
and we do know based on launch CAD of
Xbox game studios based on now we know
ABK right and
Bethesda you could have a insane killer
lineup of titles at this new hardware
launch and showcasing what you're about
to do so that does show strength and
then like to your point King PS5 I mean
PS5 Pro is already out you then Lea frog
that right pretty quickly it it because
let's be honest a lot of the fear of the
um you know the Xbox fan who wants the
mid generation refx is like damn you're
just going to let them be out there with
a PS5 Pro just and we all know them
digital Foundry joints going to come out
right and they going oh this is how GTA
6 looks over here you know say this is
how it looks over there on your platform
and we know how damaging that was for
Xbox one too and could you imagine a
Call of Duty yes that they can only get
streaming on their joint because their
Hardware is not capable to run it yeah
and and what I like about it is
dictating your own terms right coming
out you set the brain cuz like Nintendo
they move to their own drum they're not
waiting for whatever move to your own
dictate your own pace and separate
yourself because let's be honest as much
as people don't want to admit it we have
to admit PlayStation is a global brand
we have to admit that so if you keep
going head tohe head and launching your
stuff at the same time with a global
brand it's not smart you got to be
honest we got we have to be real about
the situation now if you put yourself
out there establish yourself out as this
is the place to play oh by the way oh
here's the new gears oh here by the way
here's the new perfect doc oh here by
the way here's blade here's Clockwork
Revolution here's oh by the way in the
2-year window cuz we have to admit that
launch lineup of the 360 the first year
to two years are
insane like the whole conso generation
was insane but particularly the amount
of games that came out go Rec was like
bro it was just massive and now you talk
about playing these games on more
powerful Hardware that's super
attractive right and you establish Game
Pass as and I told people all the time I
don't care what nobody say that Call of
Duty is in Game Pass is going to hit
different and Sony said it themselves I
even Sony said it you know what I'm
saying it's going to hit you got the
call now they can't but legally they say
yeah we a we ain't got no statistical
advant no no advantage over y'all except
with new hardware
though hey we can't we can't hey this
our stuff more we can't say nothing
about that right at this point so I
think that's cool my only fear I have
one fear about it one concern is that
provided that pivot did happen and there
is this change and they are now doing
this my only concern please the yields
y'all the yields please cuz we we went
through a red ring of death cuz y'all
you know moving a little fast you know
what I'm saying so so just please from a
hard that AI CH messing up just whatever
I I I hope Jason Ronald and the teams
have have really you know dialed in as
far as that aspect you know what I'm
saying because that's the only thing
that could really derail that if if
you're you know you're moving a little
too fast but look these guys are in
positions way smarter than me they they
understand the business they understand
design and all that other kind of stuff
but um yeah and then the messaging the
messaging has to be airtight I have
confidence in Xbox Hardware messaging
though when it comes to man for
promoting hardware and controller oh
they going you going to get the graphic
the you you going to get it all you
going to get so they got to do that but
they got to also really promote the Game
Pass element as as well as that launch
lineup and and and the message to
current series exits old it's just hey
this is how you're going to be able to
play the games we're not going to leave
you behind and if it will be the cloud
will allow you to play on the series as
so a series Xbox next only game so to
speak that kind of thing so look that's
going to be the key for them but yeah I
think it it would be a sound approach
I'm actually coming around to it a bit
more so yeah I wasn't down with it in
the beginning yeah at first I was a
little cuz I like do I need to do that I
was like would you fight them then I
thought about it I was like then I saw
the paperwork and I was like get
him but that's all like go go ahead guys
anything else before we move on no just
I just think that that that's the smart
play it it works on many levels that you
get ahead of the competition you really
do also reinvigorate the brand and the
reassure the fan base and Phil Spencer
is aware of the fact that people like us
uh are a bit annoyed about the console
being
relegated you know to so you that
addresses that and and the marketing
push that's the big one Xbox has
everything there it has the games it has
everything going for it but people still
don't you know with the even with Game
Pass it's not marketing well but once
you do this then you have the best
chance Xbox everything this is the
problem with Xbox and so I got so
annoyed in 2022 when they dropped the
ball killed the momentum from 2021
killed it exactly well they killed it
right off the bat cuz they had no
exclusives at the launch which is
shocking so that that it was it was
really high that that could have been a
very disruptive gen like way more than
what game pass is now they're riding on
Game Pass but it would have been really
a whole different story if this was if
this was the case but now with all these
Studios and all these IPS but the sheer
number alone that software lines up you
get your marketing beat and you got a
lot of inroads in Japan and everything
like the whole facet of this this is the
chance for Microsoft to really take it
to Sony hopefully we don't get another
Co yeah yeah that part yeah that part
yeah oh they do get another Co and the
freaking industry goes up high cuz you
remember they people sitting at home
they'll be buying conso yeah but the
thing was you know they they caught Co
bug and then Halo wasn't ready and a lot
of games wasn't ready but Sony had the
the old stuff and tuck it was like Yay
put it up to new resolution put it out
the door think think think about the
potential right we you talk about Halo
you you have all these front loaded you
have Elder Scrolls you have the new Cod
you have perfect dark have State of
Decay probably then as well stagger it
out though don't do don't do a dream
cast oh they will you know stagger it
out or show a show of force but then you
also have a future road map and what
whatever's Doom whatever was working
you have Halo remember Hal yeah remember
that the next year the following year
good point we forgot about Halo at that
time we'll probably see something
related to uh gears too the next AB
absolutely all those be one pocket Xbox
has the potential to to dominate this
industry it has everything in its
Arsenal everything the the bank the the
studios the IP I don't want these plac
dud I don't want y'all to get it twisted
right now cuz you dudes right now think
we talking about waight to 2026 no we
going to beat your breaks off every date
up until 2026 and that's when it going
to really start to happen I don't want y
oh don't get it twisted this ain't wait
till 2026 this is boot on the neck now
wor since 2026 that's what it is day we
keep that boot on your neck hash there
won't be no PlayStation 6 Kong will die
okay got it's not going to stop bro oh I
got you thank you for keeping me in line
I I know you was at okay cool keep these
beating up okay I don't think this is
like Microsoft saying wait till 2026 I
think I personally feel like they have
if they at that time they'll probably
have the majority of their Heavy Hitters
I would say Fable is most likely going
to be a cross chin game be on
both and I think that they'll puts in a
situation where it huh no I saying don't
forget about remember that Clockwork re
next out yeah that that'll probably be
time too and to me it's going to be one
of those situations where they're like
we got the Gaines we got the
services we just need fresh new hardware
to really generate hype and it's like I
said like I personally don't feel like
PlayStation will let them run wild for
years I don't I think I think
PlayStation is going to prematurely end
this generation just like Xbox
will they they go prematurely but here
the the
situation it's not about affording or
not affording it's about PlayStation
already knows what they're doing is is
blown up in their face they they they're
trying to you know have some sense of uh
and they know that what happened the 360
era so to me I don't think is there a
chance it happens again probably not but
in the back of PlayStation's mind you
can do a lot of damage in two one to two
years I PlayStation can afford to take
the risks but they got they locked into
a
PS5 but that's what I'm saying they
they'll let that they'll let that sucker
run wild for like a year and a half they
GNA cut
it hold on hold on hold let me get the
rebuttal real quick okay all right so
this is why they're not g to do what you
talking about um they just got to the
point where they making some bread off
of these consoles and they still selling
these things aren't going to stop
selling so why go to part where we
losing again on Hardware just to go to
beat somebody that we feel that we could
beat anyway let them do what they're G
to do we just started making some M
we've seen from all these leaks they
don't feel like they they feel like
they're going to get leap frogged they
they don't feel that way though right
but they just started making some money
so why you going to put out Hardway
they're gonna put them deeper into the
hole let's build our bank up so we can
come at these dudes a little bit harder
and they do they want to do Zen and you
know what's crazy let's say that they
let's say it does come out 2026 and
Playstation 4 does wait till like 2028
then then micro that's when Microsoft
can launch the slim the pro potentially
announce their Pro if they're going to
make one I mean the the leak does say
that regardless of whenever PlayStation
6 the bad word here when wrong king um
whenever that does um happen that they
were going to launch a pro in combed
that regardless so even you okay I am
with you guys I don't think they're
going to have uh I don't think they're
going to have a uh any form of like a
version of the series s now the
streaming thing is a possibility off of
King but I I think they are done with
the two SKS console I forgot to mention
that yeah I think I think they I and and
not to mention if if you launch in 2026
and there's there's no new console
around you at all and nowhere in the
foreseeable future then why would you do
it you don't need cuz you can you're
going to be the only person on the
market why you need to fight to see the
reason they made the series s and the x
is because they needed they needed the
fight on the the the the value and the
fight on the power but by then they'll
have power because they'll be out two
years after the pro and on top of that
there's no reason to fight value cuz
they're the only ones there I agree no I
100% G was going to say something for
him before no I was agree with adct the
series s doesn't need to exist because
you're nothing not beating anyone on P
Price that's the whole point about the
design of it which which is a definitive
shut down of that strategy and I think
that strategy has just kind of going to
call call it quit so yeah it makes
perfect sense man and I hope Xbox have
faith in the brand because uh I'm sure
the next topic is going to be about good
transition you it let's just go right to
it if you don't mind let's just wild
Super Chat let's just jump right into it
cuz gas does set it up so this is the
hot one man this is this is the hot one
right here shout out to uh good friend
to the realm Tom Henderson also um Nate
the hate uh lot of talk going on right
now about Xbox
exclusives and
uh C sign that's what I was going to
start with but um look there's a Rover
you know that um an Xbox highly
critically acclaimed Xbox first part it
got worse during the show jez actually
posted something oh what jez said let's
get it let's get posted an article that
was pretty much like Microsoft is
considering releasing uh let's go let's
go bring it up bring it up I'll read the
hle you read that one
rum suggest m is bringing more games to
Nintendo switch and Playstation but
what's the truth and he's it's it's an
editorial it's editorial okay got you
got you got so yeah so pretty much you
know he's saying he's pretty much
hearing Microsoft in the back or
entertaining the idea of bringing some
of their back lock to other platforms
I've also heard the same thing which is
why I got a lot of hate and I you know
you know what I I I want the future to
be Gaz you were wrong here's some Crow
eat it and I I would gladly eat it I say
I was wrong I was wrong the
crap please beat the crap out of me I
deserve to beat beat the beat me to a
for please being wrong I want to be so
wrong I say I'm wrong I'm hearing it
from very reputable s and I know
everyone says IR reputable sourer but if
I say more I get them in trouble lose
their jobs these people I trust and
again it's speculative because we don't
know like the even he says like oh she
says
um even nervous there up the don't blow
up the sauce
gas uh they saying look you never know
things could change but things are quite
Advanced on some of these things and I'm
just like
look I know satin Adella had to take a
little hit on his bonus and then you
have to convince the shareholders and
Game Pass Subs at the plateaued and
whatnot but you went in with $70 billion
what was your plan like you do you do
this you do it depends on what games
they are like would would we really care
like I'm and it's not Dam you might call
it damage control but this is something
I personally well do I give a damn if SE
thieves or grounded was as gas games
appeared on Playstation I'm like not
really cuz that could probably benefit
the the the players name as life service
games right then where do you draw the
line Halo no don't
you about Starfield Starfield go over
there Starfield yeah that would be
that's not
happening going out there going we
moving that over there exclusive for now
so I I I I just want and I'm trying to
like jostle the community not to come at
me for saying this but come go at
Microsoft to say shut up if this rumors
is true and it maybe rumors or
speculation kill it kill it before they
even because we know Microsoft's
reactive to Fan feedback with the gold
price and everything with the console
really you need to tell them to shut up
Phil Spencer stop doing this I'm not
saying you're doing it Phil but stop
committing to this Kumbaya thing and he
himself said in 2020 I don't really love
this idea that for every one of our
games there comes this little rumor oh
it's going to end up on switch or not
but that's I feel we should set a better
expectation with our fans than that so
why are we having this conversation
today you failed in that end it end it
definitively shouldn't be hard for you
to say look what I said before some
platforms where Game Pass exists that's
it don't worry guys we are all behind it
doesn't hurt you for saying that so we
we need that Xbox fans need that and if
Xbox do do it it's a slippery slope and
it it calls into to just completely it's
the worst worst thing the Xbox just give
up at that point cuz I was like we rally
behind this brand cuz we've been
following it for decades and we have
this vision of what the can do and
you're essentially removing yourself as
a competitor some people disagree with
the idea of what competition means here
but I think you being in the hardware
space and you having your exclusivity C
you as a competitor and when you get
this gray area and some games are gray
last dusk Falls but it doesn't no one
cares big bigger deal but if you start
the slippery slope and it's just really
going to
undermine uh the the effort you put into
it the mass Market thinking oh it will
come to PlayStation eventually can't do
that man and you have to be clear what
games are we're going to allow some
games what games how do we know which
games you're going to allow in the
future you can't have a question mark
yes all messaging Ming let me let me ask
you this gu so like so so let's get to
the elephant in the room C to ederson
right Nate the game that people are
concerned about is high five Rush High
rush so so how would you feel guys if
you wake up in
we the new Nintendo Direct
happens and you see chai and 808 on the
new Nintendo switch coming this fall how
you feel about
this do do you think uh what what about
the business aspect I mean you know it's
going to sell like hot cakes over there
we need we I think it would we need to
understand the parameters and how wide
this goes if highi Rush goes to Nintendo
switch I personally wouldn't I love
highi highi Rush the switch is just and
it runs in its own lane like what what
differentiate switch from the you know
your mobile device you play a game pass
on that right uh it's not a game pass
thing but James Morrison says I'd have
he have nightmar he have nightmar he
definitely messed up in a game right now
but I I personally don't think the
switch is a problem for me and you might
call me a conso oh but if we hear that
state of
play
to to PlayStation fans get ready
shy you on my head the whole time your
timeline going to be
crazy can happen can happen no now is
this the emotional of a of a hardcore
Xbox guy not looking at the business as
well business call as well because
ultimately what you're doing is you're
diluting the value of the Xbox which
you've already done by making this PC
and everything stuff you cannot kiss
move smiling
like do it it's a huge L and I will call
it out it depends on what games are
coming like grounded and okay pent like
okay pent comes to
switch that oh you're okay you're okay
but don't they get their grubby hairs
off off chai high five they can't have
that they can't yeah I mean that's a
what oh hold the line mustard heart talk
mustard heart talk we falling for a king
hold the line all right I got you I got
you but we I got to speak to my homies
first though cuz cuz G and kid are
perfect for the show for this reason
they have been on the front line saying
they are tired of having to ask this
answer this question about XBox
exclusive will it will it be will it and
now we got some reputable sources King
that that that are SA
potentially that this title that came
out as a stealth drop right that is
beloved could be flirting with the
[Music]
Enemy I got you hold gas so so gas
absolutely under no circumstance it's
it's PlayStation that can't go on then
it's a problem canot cannot do that
cannot do that cannot sleep like that
that's just crazy man right all right
kid I got to get you real quick cuz kid
you been on the front line you been on
the front line since PC came into the
picture and that and that one hurt um
and it's just PC um I'm I'm with G it's
like you can't do that especially after
this Activision stuff when they will
sabotage that deal and they still trying
to sabotage the deal after you done
signed an agreement with them like my
thing is is that I even Nintendo it's
like all right whatever like I'm with
gas with like Nintendo I don't look at
it as like it's like all right whatever
when they got Orie cup yeah there's a
precedent ay and Willow was both of them
and the sequ is over there yeah they
already got the so it's like go ahead
send bleeding edge over there like I
don't s some old stuff don't you be S it
the new the new hotness
okay like actually hellblade didn't get
ported to switch until after Microsoft
bought him by the way H blade got to
switch on like 2021 maybe um so it's
like the switch yeah I don't care I I do
wish there was some give and take though
does Nintendo and Microsoft have a
relationship like they both
collabor yeah but they got to be like
give us that bonetta give us that uh the
with Astro chain give us something throw
us a bone brother love show me some love
brother throw see like a one-sided
relationship to you that's what you say
they keep getting all our stuff that but
the minute you bring PlayStation into it
it starts to become problematic because
the thing is is that show some like Xbox
is already devalued right because of
like the PC and cloud gaming they keep
talking all this nonsense stuff and then
you have to start to worry it's like all
right what is the point for the platform
the console like I'm a DI hard console
gamer but the console I choose to play
on is Xbox and if you start taking away
the weapons or the reason why I play on
it what is your plan if you're either
all in or you you're all out and I just
yeah like I I proposed in my video today
that I um put out it's like yo go if if
you going to do this then go the way of
these mobile PCS allow all these
manufacturers to make Xboxes and then
you just put out the software that a
bunch of Xbox stop playing oh yeah like
you know what I mean it's like I it's
it's a weird scenario it's like and I
want them and this sounds horrible but I
want them to Value the Xbox
Fanboy EOS system I mean I don't even
think it's the fan I think it's the eem
the PlayStation Fanboys until they can't
afford it I mean that it's it's
happening but the thing is is like at
some point they got to Value the Xbox
fanboy like you got to value that fandom
I don't want no MK no T-shirt I want an
exclusive I want a reason to like prop
up like the Xbox console and you get
into Muddy Waters and it does we're in
we're in the area of social media and I
feel like honestly console gaming the
market is the console Wars and Fanboys I
feel like they're dictating what people
should buy in the stores because people
underestimate how popular social media
is the Twitter and YouTube and the
talking points regarding Xbox compared
to PlayStation is like by PlayStation is
become Apple tized um and I do think
there's still time for I feel like
Microsoft is at a time and Xbox is at a
time where they literally are in
position to do what PlayStation has done
it them and money they right at the C
ABK just got like why I do this now
right you got was it the glove theity
gun let go snap your dang on
fing St the finger erase them from
existence stop playing give it all away
if you could literally just have give
yourself five years just to do what they
did to you so like I got no more Kum
y'all snaap them out of existence snap
them out of just give them a taste and
right right when they're on the brink of
bankruptcy then give them all the like
wait
wait y kid that was
cold like don't do it right now don't do
it right now don't give him a chance to
breathe finish
like I feel you you speaking for the
heart brother you speaking for the adct
you up man where you at with this
bro ah I feel like they just them
stepping on rakes again and you know the
fact that hearing this from multiple
sources I I think it's it's happening I
don't know what to degree here's the
thing though people sit there and they
go out there and they say you know
Microsoft can't announce
uh any game without the exclusivity
being in question stuff like blade it's
like they they're they own the self to
blame for that it's like the reason
people are very open with PlayStation
when PlayStation does it is because
PlayStation is very clear for the most
part yeah that's ours yeah that that's
ours but Xbox is like that's ours for
now there's no question when it comes
switch it or like you know cuz it's like
I said when they first bought Bethesda
and and Phil was clear that we bought
one of the reasons we bought this is for
Value in our console Market when
Activision was first bought I saw people
like Paris be like it's not even a
question these are
exclusive because Phil came out there
and he said this is ours right and then
within a day feels like what kind of
like and then and then the blade we're
gonna put this out on the stage but we
won't put our name on it like it's just
like why this is only Xbox happen too at
this point it's just like just go third
party or don't go third party like stop
it stop playing like like and people
like oh you know what what what's help
no okay moov been waiting for this day
he tired y waking up to I thought it was
G to be aie because Orie I thought in my
mind maybe moon has worked some kind of
some kind of arrangement with xx and got
the the the IP of ory because they kind
of did something similar with with Allan
Wake when it come to remedy gam so I was
like maybe Microsoft's doing more of a a
backend seat where they're like if these
IPS and we can't do nothing with them
and their developers aren't going to
work on them and they want them let's
just sell it to them and get some some
money out of this so I thought okay
maybe that's what it is and Moon Studios
has published that game on uh on
PlayStation and then people like high
five Rush you mean to tell me that one
of the most successful games they've had
in years they're like that's not ours
finally a banger yeah that that's not
ours it's just it's just crazy man
because it's just like high-fi rush and
any other year would have been a gaming
air Contender factual factual last year
was a phenomenal that that that those
years don't happen often that's a fact
it's just like it's crazy because like
you you look at it from that standpoint
it's just like why at this point if they
buy anything you know open come at
everything like it's just it's
frustrating because Xbox will have I I
don't watch basketball like an aloop or
whatever they get the alop is right
there right there get the alop and
instead of instead of doing it they're
like I'm going to pass it to the person
behind me and then he trips and does
five somersaults and the ball goes up
and then and then PlayStation dude grabs
it like it's just like come on
man you day is tight with us y he's so
Furious he about to go in on us I
continue first I got you K there needs
to be and I know what he's going to say
hold the line some great song there's a
lot of must heart talk K don't like
this talk that's fine you know who you
need to aim that that attack towards
King Microsoft for they crummy ass
messaging langage if Microsoft would be
clear on how they handle situations and
business don't try to duck these shots
now if they would be clear on how they
handle stuff there would be no
conversations we know we know what would
be going on now I can see the Call of
Duty thing being you know the Activision
thing okay you know legal they barely
got that we we we had to make we had to
make arrangements been an but but when
it comes to like Hi-Fi rush we can argue
that Hi-Fi Rush is probably the the
closest thing they've had to a game of
the year Contender besides Starfield in
years
it's like oh we got this and it's like
they they got a they got that like they
got the golden ticket from Wily Wonka
and they're like let me bring corporate
car in for a quick second though um so I
know you hate him I know you hate him I
but we got we got to let him talk
sometimes so the question he going to
say is all right now I hear y'all right
but we done crank the numbers and this
high- five Rush is a perfect fit for the
Nintendo like they cranked the numbers
that the Xbox one was going to do well
at the gate like they cranked the
numbers that the was going over the
market like they crank the numbers like
mixer was going to do phenomenal
corporate C finish I just want ask a
question so the question is now we did
the metric right and they about to jump
out with a new conso new console and we
know they will buy this thing hand off
and we we we may have made a
miscalculation by making that a stealth
drop you know what I'm saying we ain't
get that retail like we and now we get
that on the back end plus some just for
existing and you know we friends with
them we we cool with with Bowser in the
game you know what I'm saying it's only
a matter of time this could be one of
the things to get us put them in
the TR the the trade is all right we
going to get game pass over there this
this is part of the negotiations this is
the remember Bowser said he liked the
relationship remember when the dirt came
out
when relationship remember when the dirt
came out Phil said yeah we want have B
him everybody thought it was going to go
left and like no we're still cool with
those guys we're still feel them on that
but you could say the same concept over
there at PlayStation when Ratchet and
Clank was barely making profit if made
profit it could have easily be like make
no Profit just read they didn't make the
gates we're going to let it go
everywhere that ocean over there we want
it over there that ocean we want it over
there but they didn't they're like we
made our we we made our stances we we
understood release dates and we're going
to we're going to we're going to hold
that and Xbox like high five rushed it
and okay open that gate that gate there
there you know that one down there we
need that what if that side in
corporation is winning what if that that
group is winning and say they beating
out the group that want to say
exclusives see here's the thing that
side of the corporation is the reason
the Xbox has to drop almost everything
they pick up after time like I said
mixer what else they didn't they make
Zoom like the hand little music thing oh
Zoom zua okay got you
phone what happened to Windows Phone
well then just don't try nothing right
that's what you say just don't my point
already trying my point is is we already
trying something we already in this
market what saying
okay my point my point to
that just because the higher ups think
something I just gave you multiple
scenarios where they thought something
there too and it didn't work out all
right so that's hold line hold line a k
man there a lot of lot of soft talk that
I know you a appreciate but uh we had to
talk about it this is the rumors that's
going on right now you know high five
Rush potentially one of those games that
could be rumored to Nintendo switch or
other platforms so uh how we feeling
about
this are you
Cadets here we go all you Cadets I want
you to take a long hard to look at these
mustard harded chicken chested
individuals with the Jelly back spines
and I want you to never walk they walk
because all I hear is fear in their
heart
it's
real I'm now now now we do have a little
couple of Nations that we're cool with
nation all right and we are cool The
Sovereign Nation of Nintendo we are cool
with the Nintendo Nation they don't they
don't tread on our land we don't Tre
tread on their land and we do happen to
have a lot of things that we want to do
we giv them a military armaments we have
been if you have looked bjo Kazi is over
there right now and Smash Brothers M if
you have looked ay is over there right
now MH so individuals is making a bunch
of hooply over nothing
oh now them other dudes them snitches
those rats oh man them
backstabbers those individuals that are
soft to the car those liars and
deceivers you won't get anything
here you get Popeye's
biscuits the same that we've been giving
you absolute fist full of nothing uhhuh
you can take that one to the bank there
take to the bank now Nintendo we like
the way they move over there that she
she look cute she look
fine but that's not holding the line is
it cuz we definitely want some of that
market we definitely want to slide our
game pass up in their
situation right so win game pass is
running shot over there when we uh you
know put that little Trojan Horse up up
in in there and we get them over there
to play over there and have some fun
with our stuff uhuh that's what we're
looking for but listen high five Rush
definitely you dudes ain't playing it
you dudes ain't buying it it's in Game
Pass right now yes they having fun with
it right all right all right so let's
put it over there for that $70 let those
guys get over there let them have fun
with that over there on that new Switch
that's going to launch
cuz they they was the first ones in line
to sign that Call of Duty
contract so why not
reward down with you all right so so now
what what what about what's next
Nintendo in court the Nintendo point us
out no so why y'all got a problem with
little old
Nintendo nintend shows up on PlayStation
though but them PlayStation
dudes highi Rush shows up on play
station what if Godzilla comes in and
Stomps your house down right now what
all day it ain't going to
happen it ain't gonna happen
uhhuh so let's all stop with the fear
mangarin fear Mong and and all this
chicken chest
talk but King you have to General you
have to admit that if one of these
weapons keep going over to Nintendo one
of our best weapons goes over Nintendo
what fun with it what's the the
precedent that it says that that now
maybe every XBox exclusive we got to ask
you General is that going on nintend got
ask nothing going to Nintendo's new
system well they can't run is a vow
going to Nintendo new system we know
what they can run and what they can't
run okay okay we gave them we gave them
an atomic bomb that they can handle yeah
they cannot run a lot of things they run
certain things metrics over there and
they able to do high five Rush let them
Rush on the high
we want to be in on the launch too okay
so clear in that's right we want when
you turn on that little old Nintendo
switch we wanted to say Xbox
studios Okay and we want y'all to say
wow this game was fun I wonder where I
can get some more of that oh give him a
taste than the sequel and the DLC over
on okay I see get them high on your
supply let him get a taste give them
some give them some and they want part
two you know where you got to
go all right so just give a so just to
be clear as as a reward we trying to get
them hooked as a reward for their
loyalty during the Great War of ABK the
peace treaty was signed with Nintendo
and th
this and this was a reward this how we
rewarding our mutual Ally in combat see
this is how you this is how you you know
here you go sir thank you for showing up
you know because the deals was made hand
Shanks was done you ain't going to
snitch on us right because Nintendo
could have came in and threw a monkey
wrench in the whole situation is that is
true that is true Nintendo Loy we don't
got no problems with those dudes they
great with us facts they did say that
they did they held the line they they
Advanced the line for yall and they
signed first and they show their
signature we signed with them yes they
they capitulated you are correct they
did capitulate well then let let let us
use Mario Zelda and
now that's later don't get all greedy
get greedy and scare her away don't try
to scare her away man don't scare away
don't scare her away now now I want you
to I want you to know this because a lot
of you chicken heart dudes and them
little mustard chest guys you got this
stuff going on over here I want you to
know this Nintendo could have royally
screwed this that is true you're right
and Nintendo stood so why not give a
high five why not she need a little high
five in the Life y'all two together are
going to kill
both and you ain't going to kill Kong by
yourself oh you think you going to kill
that grade eight by yourself that's not
g to happen you got to make sure they
climb the Empire State Building okay
then you send Nintendo to shoot them
down and then while you down there you
kick them while they falling you got to
make sure that they don't make it it's
going to take a two-prong effort okay
okay so this is one of our we in war
this one of our best allies we rewarding
them for a successful Mission and then
now we combin the the the switch to give
them that okay cool NOA all right Blood
In Blood Out Blood In Blood Out all sit
there and tell people you ain't about
snitching and when the dude don't snitch
you don't reward them I feel that okay
okay I get high on high fire Rush go
ahead man have a little taste a little
and then once we get your hook you know
where to come check us out come get the
DLC come get part two got to come over
here yeah you know where you got to come
all right all right down the street like
like a Motel 6 we gas a a sold I don't
think go gas is sold okay
gas I I I wouldn't mind like I don't
care that much highi Rush the switch
actually thematically goes quite well
that's okay but we need a clear
messaging because what we don't want the
Stables to run with is like well when is
our turn and it's like there's never
your turn so Microsoft messaging is the
key uh problem here it's their turn when
they get
ay uh well it's never their turn they
should never be their turn when Matt
booty is saying we can outspend them out
of business and you've spent $70 billion
you've done this what it really shows is
a lack of faith in your own brand to be
sustainable on it own on its own back
that you have to go ahead irrespec of
the good faith showed by Nintendo or
steam or whatever in signing this
contract during ABK the Xbox has a
unique uh pos position now in ABK is
it's like like Smooth was saying you've
just done the deal you've got ABK
through through an incredible process
and then you just didn't even try to
actually do it on on your own by tell
the truth and Shane the devil gas your
only true concern is
Sony right yeah absolutely okay then so
this is why I call People mustard Hut we
have not shown to be going across the
street over there with those dudes we
have not shown to be we have not no no
it's only speculation from them dudes CU
all they like to do is put out deception
and lies they want you to believe that
they gonna get something they never do
get it they wanted you to believe that
they were sustainable that they was
making money they wanted you to believe
that that ratchet and Clint could be
only done on SSD they wanted you to
believe a whole lot of things but we
come to find out that they are nothing
but lies cheats and Charlotte
so now don't fall for the banana and the
tailpipe pause I want you to understand
they will not get anything and I don't
care who writes it up or who sums it up
or who drums it up Nintendo will get
because Nintendo and the Y cell case
they did not snitch you understand no
gun situation they they didn't snitch on
young slime you got GK laughing in the
CH all right so we know who snitched and
who's a rat and not messing with they
will never Nintendo was 10 toes down in
that that's right Nintendo they kept it
g g you got to say they are they are
Italians so they kept it
a to the like no we don't do that over
here said say hey Luigi get away from
that
degenerate hey hey hey Yoshi don't you
drink out of that cup over there that
degenerate over there that Sony let's go
pack up up our stuff we're going with
Microsoft I can't with you look I'll
jump in real quick oh look I I'm not
going to believe anything just yet until
obviously we get an official Source cuz
we are speculating in in King's defense
we are speculating here thank you but
the sources are you know pretty
reputable Nintendo I mean you know highi
looks like it's definitely going to
Nintendo and that's not the problem
highi is the outlier cuz it like all too
I I I don't care PlayStation just do not
deserve you cannot you're battling them
you cannot have it and the messaging
behind that from Phil Spencer needs to
be clear why it's happening how far this
is going to go what other games are
going to come on that platform what is
the you brand it you call it something
like absolutely no the sad part about it
is this this is what I know one thing
for sure and two things for certain MH I
know everybody in that building is
pissed off at Sony for what they did
with
ABK
everybody from from from from Saia
telling you yeah if you want competition
then let us do this bro yeah let us
really swing let us really swing at you
right and and the fact of the matter is
Matt booty over there telling you we'll
spend you out of business these are the
people that's in charge these are the
decision
makers I don't know not one of those
decision makers that's going to say yo
let's reward this stupidity of these
dudes over with anything because there's
nothing over there we found out that
they don't buy games no I get Nintendo
dudes buy games no I get where you at
and I listen from a financial standpoint
it makes sense I get it it would sell
like hot cakes over there I know it will
my issue is kind of what what G say
because Phil has been on record for
saying when they asked him about why was
ay over there right yeah his message was
like L we look back at it that may have
been a mistake we we create this
Narrative of what whether or not an XBox
exclusive should or shouldn't and he
said he didn't agree with that so if the
high five Rush RBA is true it is kind of
double speak we got to be real and I
love Phil at the end of the day we so
you got to be clear to your base on what
it is because now what happens is every
single XBox exclusive that comes out is
going to have a question mark on it
nintend is it going over there is it
going over there when Nintendo get it we
have to be clear this is where
Microsoft's messaging is terrible I am
sorry I hate that about be conclusive
and stand on it stop we we can't have
this every time an exclusive comes out
will it will it it I mean but it's the
same thing with steam I mean steam was
10 toes down too and said yo you know um
the fact of the matter is we don't need
a contract with these guys it's just
rewarding those people that are standing
with you so say it so don't don't say he
can't say that you can't say
that can't but you said you said you
said
on there that wasn't the mo somebody
pull theot up say yeah I've got a quot
yeah you can't say because Nintendo's
still with us on the trial we gonna give
him this
game Spence the current position
contradicts or it it is an indication
that Phil Spencer failed to do what he
said when he said in 2020 I don't really
love this idea that for every one of our
games there comes this little rumor is
right now that it's going to end up on
the switch or not I feel we should set a
better expectation with our fans he said
that here right now yeah true true but
that was that pre ABK yeah it's 2020
2020 okay so that's preab right it
doesn't change the no it changes it
changes a lot of things you in a b if
you in a firefight and the dude that
comes over and lays down the gunshots
for you and get you up out of there and
be like yo don't worry about it we good
money I ain't going to say nothing let
me get rid of this for you handle your
business man get home safe get home safe
my guy
and you look to speak to the truth and
say yoist look these guys no no don't
tell that don't say that don't say that
why we can't say you can't say that in
the street because then then that then
then that's collusion bro that's not
collusion you just got to give a
handshake and a wink my guy and high
five shows up so then so then he can't
nobody can't get mad when we say well
what's up what hell blade that's coming
over there what's up with a V that's
going over there so again they they put
themselves
if this rumor is the game ain't there
yet though yeah that's true we we again
in speculation that's the game ain't
there yet but the smoke is there yeah
but the smoke smoker say but remember
when they were shooting at you who had
your back no I said that all right so
you got to and if yo think about it bro
like what you saying right now is so if
I if I get in that firefight I watch you
getting beat down I run over there and I
just bust shots and I get you out of
there you ain't going to look out for me
look for me I am not I'm not against
Nintendo I'm saying I've got your back
the the General that's making those
handshakes also needs to speak to the
Troops and say yo this is what we're
doing and this is where how far we you
want Phil to come out and say yo since
Nintendo held us down in the ABK we
gonna slide why you put words in myou
I'm
just I'm just saying like since Nintendo
was 10 toes down y he need to speak to
us and said this is what we doing oh so
you want him to send out the Illuminati
email so you can just get it and you can
I'll be happy with that
that's all I got other than that let let
me read the quote that Phil sent me um
yo Nintendo held us
down we got to slide them a little
something what do you think King ah send
them send them high five Rush that's
what's
up listen at the end of the day I I
understand if now now we're going to
have people saying Phil spok k d exactly
look if it was something old I be honest
you that's what I thought I I I even
though it's I confirmed I'm like all
right if it was like Psychonauts to
right you know um see a thieves cuz
you're like all right laugh service
needs to exist maybe everywhere so get
more Revenue okay fine Oblivion remaster
Fallout remaster all right it existed on
other platforms before whatever whatever
I think that's I think the emotionality
is that I think kid and and G said it
high five was kind of like their first
one yeah which was you know what I'm
saying a critically acclaimed game you
know beautifully design the whole bit
and then it's like people are like damn
like cuz even you got to admit King
you're the first one when kajima is up
on stage we got your boo we got your boo
you know saying we got one of yours you
know what I'm saying so that's what
people we going be like and it sets this
thing only that game ain't coming out
for them though it sets this thing where
people can sit there is it uh
Playstation thing we don't know or is it
no this is what I'm saying to y'all okay
is it a PlayStation thing right or is it
a Nintendo thing because we all believe
that Nintendo ain't in this fight
M thing is yeah that's true but we don't
look at them as high five Rush is the
only game really that would work there
hellblade 2 is going to be streamed no
work there right there we go exactly
like what else like most of Xbox's Games
should not be able to even work on a
switch the next gen switch if it's just
high five rush it makes sense because
it's such a good game more people should
should experience that but that's on
Nintendo except PlayStation you guys
made fun of that right that part that's
okay that's okay but it needs to be
backed by clear messaging even if it
happening it looks like it's happening I
don't care about it but so you want
Microsoft to come out and say yo we'll
never mess with those dudes but we'll
really mess with them guys no no he just
want to say this is in for this game for
high-fire rush we felt like we needed to
bring Nintendo's a lot of synergy with
this game but in terms of like then we
understand that there have been
questions around about exclusivity and
the position Remains the Same will only
go on games where platforms where Game
Pass exists this one is an outlier
because we felt like this is a unique
opportunity and we have a good
partnership and I love Nintendo blah
blah blah blah that say that it's not
hard to say and just do that there's no
harm in saying that that what if okay
what if to your point right what if to
your point that new Switch has a
accurated game pass some on it then Xbox
say is W majorly because Game Pass has
got market share on the handheld Market
in a way that mobile you have to look at
this switch as mobile game pass is like
the Trojan Horse bro this is the B
coming in now they've invited third
party in there it's going to be a Cloud
solution or whatever that's going to
make it run Xbox has got a major win
Revenue up also then you down for that
if game pass on the switch and that's
everything do see see this is where
that's a streaming
solution still everything it's still
everything but it's not the creme de La
Creme like streaming is still streaming
like you're still that the Ultimate
Experience needs to be on the Xbox
console or perhaps PC see this is why I
give a little bit of push back now
because if they do have game pass over
there that you know Game Pass is part of
the function of it is to be able to
download set games so let's say some
games is able to be downloaded in oh
let's say
Halo Halo downloaded locally I'm just
saying well I'm just saying on the
switch playing
anyway well it's still I don't know man
Nintendo's it's weird like ideally I
don't want any of it but I don't think
just telling me this is a massive wind
breath it doesn't bother me like I mean
if it's if you think about it switch so
it doesn't bother you right if it's Game
Pass like it's backed on Game Pass
that's a massive major win PlayStation's
going to be worried think about what's
happening there Xbox has increased its
Revenue massively PlayStation's looking
to die at that at that stage I don't
think Nintendo would allow it CRA so but
I'm just saying like I'm just G you the
What If part the What If part was if
they would put Game Pass there you'll be
okay with game pass on it but you're not
okay with high R the Rog Ally does that
already yeah what difference does it
make to me well just just these dudes
because I'm saying this high five rush I
don't care if it's over there it's going
to sell you get them hooked and then you
know high five Rush two come over here
yeah but you're open to Game Pass going
over there yeah Game Pass going to
PlayStation you open it that that me the
moment Game Pass goes to PlayStation
PlayStation is dead you have to
understand that it's just it's just not
workable with the third party IPS and
what not just logistically not possible
unless Microsoft says we let our first
party stable only on uh game
passur
it then kill it then that just cannot
happen but if Game Pass in his current
guys and his full breath appears on
PlayStation PlayStation has conceded
that's the point the PlayStation will be
dead before even the ps6 if that Happ
there's no way that will Happ never let
that no see what I'm laughing at is the
hypocrisy in it is that high five rush
just one game yeah just going over there
to reward loyalty yeah that's okay I
don't have a problem with it we just
want them to be clear about what they
doing and I think I think whenever the
game if the game ever goes right
whatever happens I believe they will be
very clear in whatever the message is
like this this game is over there
because the Synergy between Microsoft
and Nintendo is at this point and X Y
and Z I ever I don't ever believe that
it's going to PlayStation at all in any
form I believe the animosity in that
building is so high and is at such a
point that they want death for that
other team they will never come out and
say it
but I honestly believe they want them to
become an app honestly but Nintendo they
have an A affinity for Nintendo and I
think for some reason we all do we all
feel that Nintendo can do no wrong and
we have no problem with stuff going over
the Nintendo we like that's okay but I
was just wanted to see if you would
allow everything to go over there
opposed to just being upset with the one
title me personally I let the one title
go I don't I think that's less feasible
it could happen but it's so far-fetched
to me that that would happen if it does
happen though Microsoft has got massive
Boon that I see the switch as like a rug
Ally you can have every game pass game
there it's like what's the difference
like it's I feel I feel the same way
that's why I didn't feel a way when I
heard this stuff at all I know for a
fact it's not going over the PlayStation
but it's just PlayStation dudes we might
get it n shut up you won't yeah that's
that's all I care about man don't just
and be clear with the messaging and like
double down on it if you do high five
Rush an outlier who cares that's
actually probably good let them play
jdub can finally admit he likes High
fire R that's
f j well oh we got we beat this thing to
death out of I think that was so much
fun it was no it was hilarious it was
hilarious cuz I wanted to be bother you
to see what you was going to
say everborn are you happy now Wai for
that's what he's Wai for I wasn't going
to do it I I was not going to do uh any
hold the line or anything like that I
was
no doubt add back cuz we got some super
chats if not I'll just have as best I
can let me
see all right we had I know we had uh
Forte jig J if if we already read this
I'm reading it again because I don't
want to miss anybody remember for 29
months Happy New Year to the Lord's must
success to you this year Kong will die
no doubt shout out to Todd Howard the
alien $2 Super Chat my favorite content
creators in panel in chat hash TTS no
doubt then we got Jax 82 with the $5
Super Chat I'm going to run this series
ass into the ground before I even think
of upgrading too soon for me same with
the PS5 Pro I'm holding out all right
holding out he that that's what's up
Michael Mooney with the 5B Super Chat
Xbox on a six-year cycle would be two
years before ps6 then same time as ps6
Pro then two years after ps7 no doubt
and I don't know where you're getting
those numbers from soon as you had play7
it was over for you with as you had
play6 is over it yep Andrew Doyle $2
Super Chat XO Xbox PC hybrid will be 64
core 128 thread Zen 5 all right yeah
it's going to be crazy sju Sage $10
Super Chat the 3 to1 Playstation Andro
XBox doesn't exist because people aren't
counting millions of PC Gamers who are
Xbox series gen Gamers 360 was the last
gen you needed a console to play Xbox
games interesting all right so where you
at with it smoke show call Cali for uh
$2 Super Chat I believe do you think
Sony sent ABK PS5 Pro de kits do you
think yeah they have no choice all right
unless they don't unless they don't want
anything they have no choice and then
when you send it over we G to dissect
what
you something that's crazy this is how
this is how you kill
yourself we know what they doing all
right some Dev kits let me get that dev
kit
B Lim Reaper $5 Super Chat Xbox is
playing chess PlayStation is playing
checkers and it's almost Checkmate happy
New Year fellas # new PlayStation 6 got
he in streets he's in these streets Mr
two opinionated to Super Chat Xbox needs
to hold the line too eyeball
Emoji messy Craig huligan salute to the
membership then we got Rapture press
Network follow Super Chat Halo infinite
should go multiplat Sony Nintendo need
it they don't got Shooters make money
off back while Halo battle royale drops
too
far Popeye's biscuits they all got high
power PCS they can go play
it Raiden Blade with the5 five pounds of
J I have no problem with a game like
high five Rush go Nintendo one year
later and on PlayStation 5 three years
later it's X oh okay Xbox first making
making extra money later 70 lbs great no
man forget forget how much money
Microsoft makes as well other than you
okay find PlayStation just not in the
picture man we're trying to kill them
yeah let them die silid s for $2 Super
Chat # sliding that game pass
in God yeah pause yeah pause sir Jack
get that game
pass Jack 82 tell superat I'm not
playing highi Rush on the switch or
Metroid Prime on the Xbox keep those
separate Starfield will run like crap on
the switch Hold the Line we not Port
beging we taking over not rolling over
that's right Mike guy all right all
right hary chany the homie $10 the the
idea that Xbox games can't work on the
nextg switch is bunk it will be better
than Series S and significantly more
powerful than steam deck the next switch
is 100% going to be a competitor oh
that's good point that's good point good
point good point black Ronin for a
member for 2 months happy New Year Lord
started my birthday we week right with
some great gaming discourse Phil said
Case by case basis Case Closed stop
dooming and glooming
cheers no doubt shout out to stitch uh
oh here we go there gon to be some
Nintendo SL here putting more games on
Nintendo will give them a stronger hold
on the Japanese Market pause welcome
back Lords hash Kong running for his
life we got final one Alex $ five Super
Chat Mario said it's dangerous to go
alone take a canoli leave the cart take
the spaghetti Mama Mia it's the family
business and I think we are caught up
final topic here guys I appreciate you
if you're still rocking with the last
one and I know I got you hostage these
ilps go long I know brother um good oh
oh hold on Ice Riso $2 Super Chat soing
say do you want my spot then come and
get it oh you talk about that commercial
that was you heard King did you see that
they was talking they talking Reckless
with the lyrics I don't know if you saw
that yeah and yeah King saw that at yeah
I saw that and I said yo Aaron you need
to get at me because on God and them
they talking about you want to get the
number one spot your number one spot
ain't all that hot we can make sure that
we popped that noodle okay want me to do
a rap I can't just just me me man you
have N I know exactly listen funct how
to essentally they're essentially
arguing who's number two in the in the
industry because Nintendo's number one
facts you know this is where forse
advertisement takes presidents I'mma
tell you right now man like first of all
I saw a lot of the dudes with X is g to
give it to you know the hell with that
old stuff that x x is G give it to you
no we not no that's old this this this
is about death and murder right now boy
we're on that right there okay so if you
ain't kicking no if you ain't kicking no
King vau if you are not pushing none of
that drill rap I don't want to hear none
of that I don't want to hear none
they went for the throat and they got
very serious with you if you a put that
I whip your head boy if you are not out
there for the body I don't want to hear
nothing so don't come out here with
no none of
that don't listen has to be
Dr get at me Aaron I swear we could put
together a real and just put these dudes
away because the for them to have the
arrogance to know that they did nothing
last year and they got nothing coming
this year for them to tell you come get
my number one spot if you don't go their
head a whole third party driller if you
don't have if you don't go upside they
damn head I don't know what's wrong with
y'all you know what I live
for I live for that day where the games
Xbox starts delivering or or high
quality almost every job and then we
just see PlayStation F but we still sell
more like that's that that will sales
will always be the case cash cash is
King no doubt the hell with that I got a
m i got a whole bunch of units I sell
three to one especially when you're
counting VR headsets
and wack portal come on man get out yeah
you sold 31 think about it headset
portal and console three to one cuz we
only selling a console 3 to one do the
math y real different bro you're real
different Miguel EV that's five P Super
Chat Microsoft mobile app store will
make Sony irrelevant let alone Nintendo
no game pass on the platform you get no
games no hand shaking you steamroll them
all right all right brother he outside
with it very violent okay so we going to
move on to the final time King this is
you Horizon
MMO targeting PC and mobile platforms
use Unreal Engine 5 so it looks like um
yeah the Horizon franchise is expanding
with sequels and spin-offs uh King's
favorite NC soft is working on favorite
company now it was Nix sis before now
it's now it's definitely NC soft working
on you ain't know nothing about them
until you found out what they was doing
working MMO forp the new game is being
created with under Rion 5 will be
available on PC and mobile and uh yes
this going to be a massive role not
PlayStation no bro yeah all this time
we've been I got you bre oh Lord I got
you br I
got the new job listings uh from the
studio suggest that the pro uh project
confirms the project in the details now
there was talk about what what Gaz is
saying because initially it says there's
a different job listens with a more
precise description but in the
description there are no plans for a
PlayStation 5 version as of right now
now however he did come back in state he
said attention some people may think
that I'm suggesting that Horizon MMO by
NC soft will not be released on PS5 he
says no he said it just doesn't mean the
game won't come to PS5 at some point or
even at launch there's just no evidence
that such a version is being developed
right now so King the floor is yours I
clearly think I know where you're going
with this but uh you want to talk about
no RIS so I want to know where all the
muster heart dudes talking about is that
coming to Microsoft I want to know why
all the must hard dudes talking about is
this game coming to Microsoft it is
coming to Microsoft cuz going to PC
right cuz ain't that where Microsoft
rock at you going to be able to play
with that Xbox controller right ain't
that that's where they playing Wolverine
at right
now so if your own company don't think
you
viable don't think you enough and they
just said man just skip that whack
console all by itself let's just take
our IP and let's just go over to
PC let's get to Mobile they said my
phone my phone is better than putting on
that that that
router and y'all don't see this y'all
don't see where they going y I don't see
y'all jumping out the window talking
about are they gonna become third party
they third party right
there right there when they skip their
own console and told you I'm going to
put it on a phone and I'm G to put it on
a PC them dudes over there what's going
on with this machine that everybody else
even them don't want to rock with them
like that what's going on on with this
machine that you got CEOs selling stock
you got future games skipping
platforms what's going on this is this
is an MMO this is what they wanted isn't
this a game of service isn't this what's
supposed to make them viable isn't this
what they talked about this is isn't
this the pivot how you going to Pivot
and totally Miss what you trying to hit
like how is how is this pivot how you
going to Pivot totally pivot out of the
console
space is this not a peek into the future
where all theps decid to just pivot out
oh so oh I see what we doing now okay I
see what we doing so is NC soft just a
little bit ahead of the
curve I'm just
saying I saw this and said man I don't
see none of you Xbox
dudes doing this going after them
because if any game would have came out
for a uh mobile and PC and skip the Xbox
platform they'll be M y' be going crazy
if it's real that' be you know no this
is real as hell this is real as hell
before we've had the Loft Planet Side
was it Planet Side 2 though that was on
PC uh but Horizon is an IP that um is a
Playstation IP and if mobile and PC can
have it why can't uh play
and and you not releasing it there why
because your fan base doesn't like
multiplayer um what's going on it makes
no sense cuz you're on PC is different
unless it's going to be a diluted
experience then there's a game not even
worth talking about as well so it's like
that's one of your guest games that
Gorilla Games is committed to and all
more resources are on something that the
PlayStation fans uh one can't play but
to probably don't care about so it's
like what's going on it's a they're
really really really stretching out all
avenues here to desperately kind of
pivot this is just an indication of that
they've got a tight tight thing with
ncsoft but if it doesn't come to
PlayStation day one you best believe I'm
going to be a pain in their backside I
will I will be like ins sufferable but I
want to break protocol we got to break
protocol real quick cuz shout out to Lao
uh shimazaki uh can't pronounce currency
brother but appreciate the donation he
actually says I don't think NC soft has
ever released an MMO on console for any
game at launch so what does that mean
about that game why I make a deal with
them if it's on mobile like is it a bad
game it's not worth it to we're talking
about PlayStation like you forsake the
PlayStation like PlayStation first but
he like this game is not really for
PlayStation what does that say about the
game is it actually any good I don't
know sounds like it's like vaporware or
mobile which I guess I don't know
man look I mean I was going to let you
jump in man uh with this uh Horizon MMO
um potential PC and um mobile first or
we not sure if there's going to be uh at
the same time simult ten release for uh
PlayStation consoles your thoughts on
real you I don't
care I don't even like Horizon much less
care to play MMO The Horizon M for you n
i don't even play MMOs like that in
general so it's just like it'd be crazy
if it doesn't go to PlayStation but even
if it did I
wouldn't yeah I mean I got too much to
add on too just that it would be weird
that it wouldn't be uh at the same time
but the fact in King's defense the fact
that it's not listed initially is a
little bit of a say a flag and in a
sense that you know like why why
wouldn't it be you know what I'm saying
kind of thing why wouldn't you want that
Synergy between all three platforms you
know at the same time with with uh with
the mobile thing cuz I understand it's
most likely it's going to be more of a
mobile Style game but one would think
Horizon MMO would have appeal to to to
the console base so I don't know I'm not
going to jump out the window just yet
but yeah it is interesting I will say
that that it's myself two feet out the
window I know you all the way could be
too is we're only seeing listing because
maybe some uh so like multiple people
are reporting multiple of them so maybe
the the console version is a little bit
behind the other ones could be that's
what I'm saying like maybe like it could
be a variety of reasons or could be just
not coming out ah I mean that's
definitely a I mean n soft is is mobile
right that's what they've done right
prior right I don't know I'm sorry
maybe because if it's on PC it wouldn't
be touchcreen for the most part I don't
know man
maybe it it would be a really really bad
look for for PlayStation that that MMO
didn't show up on PlayStation that's why
like part of me feels like there's no
way when the other part of me's like
that that' be crazy yeah said you know
again NC soft they were work they
working on another game called Aon 2
which is another MMO for PC and mobile
and so maybe maybe that's just the way
they work you know what I'm saying in
general and it's like they they design
games on both of those platforms and
then you know the PS5 maybe it comes
with a later Port I don't know that is
interesting it is Unreal Engine five
though so
interesting well we will have to find
out about K&N news at some point we have
to find out how this goes but that's
what I got let me just wrap up these
super chats looks like we're good there
oh shout out to Harge miss your brother
$10 Super Chat PlayStation leads in one
category PornHub
usage Nintendo for consoles 10 cent for
Revenue might be Xbox soon Apple for
profit and Subs Xbox for um monthly
active users largest platform is Xbox PC
uh near nearly two billion players shout
out to hardge bringing the stats you
already know and I want to get the poll
and then we get up out of here so uh new
poll reference to the Xbox next in 2026
which do you think is the best approach
for the future of Xbox the choices are a
stand Pat you now have the games with
Xbox game studios ABK and Bethesda B
launch Xbox next and dictate terms of
Next Generation with a massive games
lineup on new hardware Choice C that's
gree do a mid Generation update to match
PlayStation 5 Pro instead no one wants
that or D I don't care don't give high
five rush to the
switch guys is crazy oot it will go up
shout out to kids shout out the gas the
sauce holding us down where can they
find people find you it's been a minute
brother where can they find you what's
going on uh had such a Time flew man
that's crazy um such a good time thank
you so much man this this is the one man
this podcast I'm honored to be here uh
thank you thank you for chopping up chat
you're crazy I love
it I can't get away with you what you
guys say because ASO just put me
down was free
here Mark with the $20 Super Chat just
came in as well I'll read it while I'm
doing this King could be could sharing
titles like high five Rush as a strategy
to show regularly at all we share top
titles Etc then Microsoft goes and buys
take two it puts Microsoft in a better
light to buy the next publisher that's
going to be uh Take 2 is going to be one
where they're going to take some time on
it I don't think they ever buy no take
two bro like I'm sorry I think that
asking price on that is way crazy yeah
that's like a proper proper like
European country or something that's
crazy crazy that's no
way Amsterdam combine all of that if
they do that I I will get uh [__] stamp
that says
Xbox I'mma tell you right now that ain't
happening bro let that what happens if
they do that you know people going to
hold you on that and and you know I'll
get it so he'll get it yeah and you know
I'll get it but I do not want to be
taking my shorts off at the beach The
End by the end of this podcast King
going have tattoos all around his body
I I ain't saying no more but come on the
odds of that happening to for Grand
Theft Auto 6 to be ass M you might as
well take just oh that don't even make
no sense I don't even dream that hard
pause I don't even dream that that's a
crazy dream guys where can they find you
man yeah so uh making videos on my own
channel relaunch which I've been talking
about called septic source which has
been in the work for like five months I
can't wait to show you guys what I'm
working on man it's going to be epic
thank you so much just check me out
Twitter septic source and where I bury
ponies every day fact lot of violence
but you've been good you've been good
You' been you've been talking to the
other side I see you you know I'm trying
I'm trying to broke a piece ofre you to
keep your enemies close for your
friend not me I buck shots me
daily oh my gosh guys shout out to Aces
shout out to the whole game one daily
crew and looking forward to see what's
going on with septic sauce no doubt
brother you already know and Lord addict
man could find people find you what you
got going on man shout out to the stream
earlier hey you can find me on uh
Twitter at Lord addict IOP you can find
me on YouTube at gaming addict I have my
own uh personal YouTube channel that I
dedicate to uh streaming it's called the
addict Arena I will be having you uh
I'll be streaming Liza P tomorrow nice
uh so I will be having the the stream
rating uh my my video so you guys know
uh where the actual stream's going to
take place I definitely go over there
and sub to the channel it's people tell
me elizza P actually more on the
difficult side of uh of the source
formula so it's going to be interesting
to see if that's true or not uh once
again you know earlier for you that are
not there you know shout out to uh R
Shadow Legends for uh you know
supporting the realm and uh doing a
sponsored stream on on uh on the game
you know it was actually a pretty fun
time uh it look at my last video the
last video when I uh streamed you know
there there's all the info in the
description if you guys want to go over
there and uh click that and you know try
the game out make sure you click that
link though uh you know it always helps
us out definitely uh you know gives us
more opportunities in the future if you
guys try the game out and like it but uh
we had like 1100 people almost
12 great uh definitely hit that like
button on your way out man doubt for
sure we we're going to hold your we're
going hold your boots Ransom you can't
leave so I appre appreciate it and uh
you know show up to to uh M and King we
be streaming uh Boulder's Gate and uh he
he he be doing something that I just
scratch my head every
stream I like to do bad things walking
around and then I'm in battle for no
reason because they say stupid stuff to
me like I'm not gonna like I'm GNA take
that I'm not gonna take
that I just have to be like really King
I mean they just did it like yo I said
it on that crew too add did think we was
going to get out of it but I was like we
going to get out of this we got out of
there yeah now we're about to go to the
goblins and I'm sure that's going to be
a chaotic we worked that goblins over
don't you lie we worked those goblins
over we work the mo
yeah little goblins though that a little
go we smacked that Goblin in the face
with doodle that a little go don't now
Doodle is not a curse so we grabbed it
we grabbed the do cuz he wanted to Smosh
it in my face no so I SM I smoosh the
doole in his face and then
yeah that's when the fight went on and
then we hand then we handled that other
Goblin over there that was trying to
punk you remember he was trying to punk
you I wasn't even there what are you
talking about yeah see you don't even
remember the whole situation y put the
stream up go watch the stream yo anyway
Lord King when can find people find you
not being mustard hearted Ah that's
right that's the facts first of all I
want to say uh thank you for kid smooth
showing up um he had a great loss in his
life and uh to see that he's uh coming
out of that situation and um the video
that he put up of his grandmother was
was beautiful the song that he did was
fantastic so to see him here spending
some time with us that was great um Gaz
my my my overseas brother my my brother
from another mother my guy like yo I
told you I I love the hell out of you so
anytime you as soon as I saw you I was
like I said this is about to get lit so
yo thank you for showing up thank you
for being here thank you for being in
the sauce if anybody doesn't know about
septic sauce please check it out uh he
was doing some stuff with hog geek sha
that was so dope so um I can't wait to
see exactly what yall about to do what
happened oh Lord what happened someone
someone in the chat said ad was about to
kiss some Goblin feet oh no oh God
no the gobl was telling him to kiss his
feet um guys your camera went out oh
[__] yeah yeah um you catch me on Xbox
front line Xbox Frontline news where I'm
going to continue to keep the boot on
Kong's next his whole generation which
is I will not stop so if any of y'all
guys was watching the stream and did not
know what we talk about with kill Kong
and K w't make it follow Xbox Frontline
news where you'll understand exactly
what we talking about I put out videos
daily I was sick and then uh this week
so I didn't get a chance to put out like
two videos Friday is a live show is a
call-in show uh that I do uh
we pull you in and that's a little bit
of fun there but K&N news is there and
if y'all wanted to get that t-shirt that
says uh Kong will die I'm selling that
in Xbox front line go get it is a funny
little shirt and it's fun but it was
this Felt So Good hanging out with you
guys on Sunday because I am not gonna
lie I have missed Sunday missed it so
adct has been keeping me busy uh with
the streams and stuff like that so do
appreciate adct and um n great to see
Cog face yeah man been a minute right
podcast that thing that we used to do
yeah yeah back and yo and see see a
thousand people here thousand plus much
love that's that's that's crazy love
thank y'all for giving us the
opportunity to take a break you know cuz
some people take a break and then they
come back and they see like 200 people
yeah word no that's so so thank you I
appreciate it and then I was looking cuz
I didn't get a chance to look at Twitter
and I got got a chance to look at
Twitter and see how many people uh gave
me well wishes yes and stuff like that
to get better yo anytime y'all see me
cutting off the camera it's CU I was
coughing spit no no he going through it
too man yeah this flu season is no joke
y'all that's nuts over there no joke
again don't send no love to to S he's
enjoying s for his birthday yeah don't
say No Love No Love off let the man
enjoy himself man at the Opera wherever
he at doing what he doing with L so so
that's what we got here next week should
be fun we should have some guests some
more things cooking up and anything else
add before we go get a butt out of here
are we good uh no we will be doing more
Community streams um this year we're
going to put that a little bit higher on
the priority list the problem is is like
it's hard to get us all in one room
because you know especially sa saw work
like 10 jobs so you know it's it's hard
to really find the time that works for
everyone but I think at this point we're
just going to you know try to get half
of us there if we can yeah and uh you
know go go with that you know I know
these uh these these fools over here
want me to play more if I had the head
fighting game so we'll see about that
yeah uh you know I think I think I might
just sit here and uh play on my phone
why I let whoever beats me beat me that
te that Tekken
eight play rage Shadow Legends on my
phone while you guys who in real life I
gotta download that I gotta download
make sure you use that code yes sir we
good but I appreciate covering through
and remember uh adct Arena tomorrow 5:00
pm uh I'm I'mma show the those people
that that are scared of Liza P what's up
no doubt everybody look enjoy your
Sunday we GNA catch you on next one
peace yeah and I'm taking you guys to
that to that live stream so uh
definitely sub to that
[Music]
channel